today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza and that's a great
place to get a pizza pie he's a college
football superhero and an an embodiment
of perseverance
he's one third of the business and
biceps
Podcast squad and they will be joining
us later
it is Maurice Clarett
[Music]
I've been out here about 14 years I
guess
[Music]
yeah actually I guess maybe about Oh two
or three and when when and when were you
here you lived in Los Angeles
yeah January 4 yeah January February
yeah and was that fun like that was a
was that a fun time in your life what
was that like being out here
beautiful so just from my listeners so
if we could could you just kind of if
you could under the eggs absolutely
impossible Maurice Clarett could you sum
up like kind of like football and some
of the Ohio State stuff maybe in like
you know about two or three minutes or
whatever you think you can yeah for
people who may not be familiar well you
know I came out just as a highly touted
recruit from runner nation went to a
house state in in the first time in
history started as a running back for
house state went out and went won a
national championship with in my first
year yeah a huge amount of success from
a personal level and for me you know
obviously a career level and in the
process of doing that I always put it in
context I gotta remember that LeBron is
about a year younger to me Wow yes
around that time yes so the Brawn grew
up maybe 40 minutes away from me and
this is at the height of LeBron
basically be going to become LeBron you
know in high school and he's selling out
college stadiums and at this time you
have you know 50 cents a new rapper
jay-z's fairly new yet like the
blueprint to out and I could just
remember after having so much success in
watching LeBron have his success I can
remember just me sort of losing focus as
as a college key oh I see so you kind of
said you kind of followed that it like
his path even though it wasn't your path
maybe yes you know 20 20 right yeah so I
can remember after being done with the
season and you know as an 18 year old
kid you want everything in high school
fast forward 13 months later you want
everything in college all of the adults
around
I don't blame this on them because
everybody's enjoying the moment when
you're famous or popular or
notarized nobody tells you no yeah oh
yeah you get out you get it all
everybody's just telling you yes and I
can just remember I can remember one 50
cent head in the club so it came to all
the best still one of the best albums
still one of the best albums period yes
and I could just remember you know
LeBron asked you know let's go up to
Cleveland State and let's enjoy this and
I remember Nike Reebok adidas all these
guys are chasing them and I could just
remember just enjoying that a bit too
much yeah and in a reality of it is that
I don't get a suspended from having too
many legal benefits wasn't the bras for
all right you know doing too much and I
wound up happening was and I always say
it that was probably the most impactful
time from an individual standpoint
because that was the first time I
actually felt like depression yeah you
know never at really went through
anything from a mental standpoint never
felt anything at verse from a um from a
personal level outside of sports you
know I sports if you if you have a hard
time you can you know watch film you can
lift weights you can get him better
conditioning you can you know as a
comedian you can learn how to tell
better jokes but from a personal
standpoint I just didn't know how to
process that that was a tougher thing
yeah and that's an age when like the
voice inside of your head starts to
become like a real voice I feel like at
that point you can hear it more yeah and
so you know obviously I didn't realize
that prior to that from having so much
success there was so much sex drinking
drugging yeah but it was done in a
celebratory stamp or from a celebratory
step boy I think I'm celebrating a game
or hanging out with the fellas it
switched from having celebrations to me
masking what I really felt
yeah because I can't go play sports I
can't go play a game I have no like
[ __ ] clue as to what's going on in my
life and so that's kind of like work or
life like kind of really met me at and
that's like a like a gray space oh yeah
nobody can kind of navigate out of this
and nobody knows what's going on you
know what's going on you don't want to
reveal your feelings and that's kind of
like what really had happened with me
and you probably can mean at that point
like you couldn't trust the media very
much there was like I'm sure you
probably ski not scared but just
directionless maybe I don't know yes so
just to put context to it after I got
kicked out of school
there was a two-year waiting period
before I was allowed to go to
NFL and at that time I really thought
that NFL will let me enter the draft
right you know I was big enough strong
enough and everything else but when they
didn't allow me to enter the draft I was
just kind of like sitting two years away
from football so I end up going to Vegas
to watch it was a it was a Roy Jones and
Antonio Tarver fight I go out there and
I when I watch them in the House of
Blues and Jim Brown was out there Jim
Brown hits me up he says you know you
know I remember I helped you out with
your your case at Ohio State can you
please like you know get away from that
environment you just don't look like the
same individual that I seen you know oh
wow prior to that and so that was the
original reason for me coming out to LA
so when I came out to LA he took that to
heart when Jim Brown said that yeah
because you know he had see me as the
the 19 year old kid who still was
wanting to play football and everything
like that and when he seen me at the ED
Antonio Tarver fight that was probably
seven months later eight months later
different you different me you know I
had partied all night
you know we up to four or five in the
morning you know you know that look I
said one time I used to get the goodbye
makeup did I be so I've never had makeup
in my life dude I've been in a 24-hour
CVS I like five try to get yourself
together asking people about bronzer and
blush yeah I'm just trying to pay for a
meeting in the morning
so yeah I feel you a hundred percent so
he saw you and he said he kind of just
you know commented and then you moved to
Los Angeles yeah comment and I moved out
here with the whole motivation to come
out here in the gather myself and when I
got out here what I didn't realize is
that you know he he was in North
Carolina or South Carolina wherever he
was that and there was a period of time
when I was out here by myself waiting
for him to come back out who Jim Brown
Jim Brown yeah and so when I got out
here I was like alright you know I'm
cool I kind of got away from Ohio to you
know I like during the process of me
getting away you know I got back into
the streets I'm selling dope I'm selling
weed I'm hustling
so I was full-fledged into the streets
and I'm full-fledged away from
everything sports related I'm just all
the way deep in the hood right I
separate myself I come out here because
throughout that process also and I was
talking to John this morning I got
almost robbed three times and the last
time that almost
robbed my mother was in the house you
know some guys on our bushes ended up
coming outside you know he was in the
suburbs at the time so these guys ran
off you know my dad time I was like I
gotta get the [ __ ] out of here you know
too close to home too close to home
and do you think you were in those
streets like you think you went back
into drugs and into like are into cell
in that time environment because there's
still a level of you probably got a lot
of street cred did you well I think it
was it just for the Hustle is it just
for money do you think there was because
there's a you know there's a level you
can always have a claim at in the
streets I feel like that you keep that's
different than you know in the in the
world like in society like in the
streets if you're cloud as a certain
level it's kind of always there it's a
nice space well when I look back on it
there was a few things that put me in
the streets one my brother had needed
money because he had just got arrested
right he had needed money for an
attorney the second thing that put me
back into the streets is just familiar
familiarity yeah if I can say right
right just to feel familiarity of how do
I take care of myself and I think
there's some sort of glorification that
when you come from the hood the machoism
of selling drugs and the coolness right
is attractive right so it's something
still almost as cool as athletics in a
way in a way you still you're still
allowed to be somebody right and my
access to me being able to get drugs
from people the drug that I was selling
they these people was easy to get to
these people you know so so I'm speaking
from that perspective and I gotta say
and also just from being just being a
bit more realer I was just a dumb [ __ ]
when it came to school right you know
says so there was nothing like you know
let me go ahead and get an education and
you know football's not workin out let
me go ahead and live my life and some
academic format so it just wasn't there
you just couldn't even pay attention in
school it just wasn't your turn it just
wasn't interesting like when you look
back on it when you grew up in an
environment you know like when you grew
up in an environment the only thing that
you see as being successful what you
deem successful is guys either selling
dope or the cool guys are the athletes
that's the other things you want to
gravitate to as a kid especially like
probably growing up black in America
your age I mean I remember the only
successful black man I even knew growing
up
were the guys in coming to America no
joke or the Dallas Cowboys when I really
think about it as a child like you or
the guy on in the heat of the night the
you know Virgil yeah but to see when I
think back like that's who I it's like
there was only a really yeah like I
remember enough this before yeah if I
even remember watching commercials for
like Disneyland or something like that
it was always white PBS like there was
probably yeah so I can only imagine what
the vision probably looked like being a
young black child you know yes so you
just you just put that into context and
so you got a yeah I put everything in
context yeah you're more more about
being cool as important to you rather
than ya doing the right thing and
building your life 18 19 years old oh
cool is it old is it and so they're
selling of the drawers mechanic makes me
cool to the women right they're selling
other drugs gets me money in my pocket
to do foolish [ __ ] to buy champagne to
buy liquor but you don't realize the
habits that you're forming from this are
detrimental to you yeah so at that point
I can remember I'm out and they thought
that I'm in Vegas and Jim Brown was like
yo slow down like you know like just
slow down I can remember even I remember
at that time to James Prince was out
there I remember James Prince was like
you know you tripping you know me
because he had seen me as a regular
football player and then to see me in
that condition I can remember him saying
like yo you trippin I'm sad slow your
ass down so I came out here and in the
process of Jim Brown not being around I
went down to Sunset yeah and I go down
to Sunset when I'm going into Hollywood
when I'm partying all day oh yeah you
know partying on a Monday never heard of
[ __ ] parties on the Monday party on
the Tuesday party no party on the
Thursday hey come to get this brunch but
it's Halle was crazy many books you can
always find it you can find it this
group of people that it just never ends
so so just take like this so put this in
the context I'm from Ohio
yeah from Youngstown to Columbus Ohio I
don't care how progressive you think
Ohio is if you're from Ohio it's still
slow in comparison to these larger
cities see how they do stuff so in Ohio
if you're [ __ ] drunk out of your mind
and how do you mind it [ __ ] to an
afternoon somebody would say you're
crazy in LA they walk past you like
there's no big deal yeah you know
because this is a social function and so
I got caught into that crowd and it was
just a good time
also you know how you can be very
popular you can come to LA you can hide
right nobody knows you so they don't
know that your accountability for being
a professional there's no coming right
they don't know that yeah there's no
accountability you can fake it it's all
yes there's no you can't see any of the
behind the scenes of anyone here really
no like in a smaller city you can see
you might run into maurices cousin or
maurices aunt or a friend of maurices
he's like he's not doing well or here
everybody a lot of prop everybody up yes
and nobody even knows what anybody's
really doing anyway and nobody really
knows and so from there you know
obviously a party and Jim Brown reached
out to be a couple of times and I went
to his house up in the hills and just
from the the discipline he tried to
implement on me I was resisting for you
know how much Africa is in Jim Brown's
house I bet I could see him having masks
I could see him having like traditional
Mufasa warriors like no serious dude
serious and just yeah he has a great
spirit and a great soul but if I if I
remember correctly just a bait like this
very basic house but one thing he talks
about is his view like if you go out
there you can just see the whole city I
guess a phenomenal view yeah and I yeah
he always hosts like he probably still
does it to some degree so host like
meeting at his house every Monday and
Tuesday night and bring different dudes
from different gangs all over LA towards
house and you know bring in just people
who would speak and it was just about
basically basic fellowship on life so
he's big on that yeah so yeah the
American program and this was helping
guys transits from prison giving them
job skills giving them different support
once they were released back into
society so he had felt that since he's
dealing with people who are gangsters
that they would take me in like a little
brother and provide some structure for
me to basically get better a great idea
but I just wasn't ready for already you
don't sound like you know yeah you can
in my mind I was a celebrity in my mind
I'm like [ __ ] I'm somebody from Ohio I'm
not about to come out here and listen to
guys and have structure and discipline
and go to bed it's hard to hear it's
hard to hear when you're a celebrity
isn't it yes when you think about when
you think you so everything right right
when you think you're a celebrity when
your ego really starts to puff up it's
hard to you can listen to people you can
look at people but it's hard to really
hear them it's
sometimes it's this different I would
cause there's no discernment right so
because this is what happens you you get
to a space with how you've always wanted
to live your life alright so you know I
grew up in the MTV Cribs air oh yeah
right oh yeah so to a kid that is
impressionable you know if I made it you
know like who doesn't like like you know
I have a woman weaving out of 14 years
right
but in that space I want to have sex
with the most beautiful women yeah I
want money everywhere I want to [ __ ]
bitly outside on a Rolls Royce outside
I'd want to live life oh yeah so
anything that you get Tigers everybody
gets so you don't say you you you get to
a you're living some sort of pseudo
moment in your head you don't want to
say it right and so now you're coming to
me as an advisor with a great advice and
I'm like [ __ ] like it makes sense but
this isn't helping me to do all this
[ __ ] that I want to do right like this
isn't helped me you know [ __ ] all these
girls this isn't helped me be cool in
the club and fame is like fame or
notoriety is [ __ ] intoxicating its
intoxicating especially when you don't
have a lot of feelings already inside of
yourself that kind of that you can
notice that sort of thing like you don't
have like a real framework or a
groundwork that builds you up from the
inside any you know anything and I'm not
saying that you don't I'm just saying
that my own life you know like I know
that there's things it's like man when
things come in that seems appealing yeah
but you actually sell when did you
figure out the discovery process of
knowing yourself you know nobody's
thinking 1819 years 85 maybe come on
listen to me I'm still at what do I
value how do I love myself you know what
is really important to me I'm sitting
down today what John having coffee I
said man like I'm having fun sitting on
a table outside having coffee at
Starbucks yeah I could appreciate just
cars going by you know I'm saying right
different different appreciation oh yeah
I mean it's uh yeah I mean I gotta you
know I'm a sober guy now so I got in a
program about two and a half years ago
and that's that's the first time that I
started learning it that's the first
time I could almost really even hear
anybody like before that life was just
this it was great and there were great
moments and it was I was I was involved
in invest
but I just couldn't I don't know the
things hadn't lined up enough it was
still too much of a Rubik's Cube you
know for me um but not to take your
story away so so you end up back out
here Jim Brown has you up in the hills
he's trying to help out yes sir sorry
that's I'm I disconnected from him and
all things responsible in the data
coming in uh I met another gentleman Rio
still a good friend tonight smart still
a good friend to me today and his name
was hot you know he was obviously the
34:30
oh yes I'm in the 30 for 30 yep so and I
met hi and at that time hi was under a
federal federal case and all federal
racketeering cases and and highly noted
and all over the Internet and so what
happened was we end up going to a party
at his house and I he lived out in the
marina and as we went to the party at
the house I ended up bumping into him to
make a long story short you know we was
just talking [ __ ] to each other just you
know like who are you where you from
like how did you get out here we need a
party in some more that night and then
you just like yo like you kind of from
Ohio you've landed in LA you don't know
anybody out here like you know hook up
with me like let me help you get your
[ __ ] together and I don't really
understand like even how it happened he
want to look back now but it was like
one of the best it was one of the best
and worst things happened to me the best
because I got a friend and a brother for
life like that was that was guaranteed
there was also like a cool deal of just
me getting exposed to other people who
are successful outside of athletics okay
right you got an en croute yes so I
never knew somebody so they day on the
shits on the real estate you know
probably a couple billion dollars worth
of real estate and I can just remember
thinking to myself I'm like how the [ __ ]
are these people so rich you know right
as naive as it sounds at 20 19 20 years
old I never seen somebody who had had
money outside of athletes I couldn't
even conceive alright people being like
that massively successful and so what
ended up happening was that he was under
a racketeering case you know at that
time and he was getting ready to go to
trial like maybe that next summer right
and so every day he would get up at 8 in
the morning and he would have his curfew
at 11:00 but he thought he was going to
prison for a long time so it was all
about living life to the fullest okay
you were in you were on that way and I
was just happy to be a part of the blast
so
I'm out here trying to semi train for
football nothing really serious and I'm
also around him every day because this
is the only person I know right so we're
talking about guy who has three or four
[ __ ] Bentley
oh yeah the [ __ ] house in Beverly
Hills a house and [ __ ] by the beach
and just seeing that as a young man it
can't hit really
I could imagine probably in your
scenario I don't even I don't know if it
could help that much seeing all that but
it makes it worse and I gotta say this
one of the worst things that can happen
is that you get into a vehicle you get
around people who are super successful
and you lose sight that this is their
success you're just living in it yeah
you know say oh yeah so the hunger for
me to want to become something had faded
because I thought I made it yeah and 19
20 years old you not processing like
this is their [ __ ] right you know Sam
but you have a sex with beautiful women
you know there's a lot of beautiful
Saudi Yemen out here right yeah your sex
belt out here man it's the sex belt
think about this you have a Mercedes I
got a 2004 five Mercedes 600 for in my
garage is 2004 you have a 745 out here
some brand new cars you live in the
marina yeah you know you got money in
your pocket your party they've got
goldfish made out of real gold
never swim I don't know if it is a heavy
man yeah that's a 14-karat flounder
right yeah so you so you so you have the
bad scenario you get caught up you you
have you have influences but but their
life isn't your life and you're starting
to believe that it is or of course if
that is who wouldn't I'm starting I'm
starting to it's but it's easier to live
the life and you end up in Sioux and I
remember you ended up back in the NFL
yes combine yes I went back to the NFL
went to the combine failed horribly I
ended up coming back to LA and as I come
back to LA I'm thinking like I'm not
gonna get drafted anymore and after I
end up getting drafted in the third
round I went to Denver and it really was
just a [ __ ] show in a nutshell I
couldn't stop partying I was literally
going to the clubs and well stay out so
maybe three or four in the morning and
we have to be the practice at 7:00 so
I'm coming to practice in the morning
like [ __ ]
you know saying not just a professional
athlete and I always talk about Denver
because I can't I can't really [ __ ] on
Denver they tried to help me right yeah
so throughout the process
they tried to sit me down with a sports
psychologist and they said hey you know
can you please slow down you know get
with the sports psychologist and allow
her to assist you because they kept on
saying you've experienced a lot of
trauma before you've come to here right
yeah
instability so at my bottom like okay
I'm not about to sit here and talk to
this lady one because she was a lady in
two I think that I'm a gangster and this
is like oh wait lady talk to me about
singing to help ignorance you know not
that she has some information but just
pure ignorance so you fast forward a
story we're getting ready to play the
Indianapolis Colts this is the third
game of the preseason they come to me
again they said hey can you sit down and
work with the sports psychologists would
also get on the practice squad like just
sit yourself down like allow us to
develop right in my mind I process that
as I'm not good enough and you want to
sit me out yeah couldn't see the forest
for the trees right yeah so the next
thing you know I push her away they
called me that next day they cut me that
morning I end up getting on a plane
coming back to LA and when I got here
you know the depression went from like
you know - yeah a negative 40 all right
it's building behind the scenes you
don't even know it no absolutely it's
such a monster the way that depression
and that kind of stuff endings all of
they can be building in your base and
you don't even realize a lot a percent
100% and when I get here this one under
I was real [ __ ] up like sometimes like
you know you have moments of clarity or
you can identify you really feel I went
to a party off a sunset and I could
remember like it was yesterday I'm
standing the party and as I'm standing
there the whole party's going on and I
literally had smoke before I came I had
drunk before I came and I literally felt
nothing
damn didn't feel ha didn't feel drunk
didn't feel connected to the moment
didn't feel the party didn't feel the
music like just was like in it's like
stale space yeah so anybody ever been
[ __ ] up off of drugs not talking about
right so the next thing you know I get I
get in the party I'm [ __ ] around and
I was like man I gotta get the [ __ ] out
of here I just knew I had exit LA yeah
so I get back to the house I went to
like that time I was banking with the
[ __ ] whoever that next day withdrew
my money because they didn't have the
same bacon Ohio caught a one-way ticket
to Ohio and went home left all my [ __ ]
right so I connected with my coach when
I came back home and when I connected
what even the whole thing was like hey
you know I need to get my [ __ ] together
I feel lost like I'm just like totally
disconnected from
[ __ ] reality so I end up coming back
to Ohio when I got back here
the kocha gave me a bunch of
instructions like you know a bunch of
[ __ ] to do to help me direction again
direct you follow it no but he always
talked he always talks about coach
Tressel always talks about takeaways
after we're done talking and I said you
know I needed to go back to school with
and I also need you to get in better
shape the first thing was like [ __ ]
shits on art because I couldn't get back
at school because I didn't know how to
do the [ __ ] work right so I was
rejecting that in the back of my head
the second one I said okay I'll start to
get in shape so as I started to get in
shape and wake up and go to the gym that
he referred me to like I started to feel
better look better the whole night but
what happened was that a ton of free
time on my hands right some 21 at this
time ton of free time on my hands no
money can't pay for rent really didn't
have like the humility to go get a job
right back to the street yeah back to
the streets to see he's still the king
he always a king there in my mind right
yeah my - so I get back in the streets
and as I'm getting back into the streets
the drugs are not as accessible as they
were before because the guy who was my
see what he ends up going to the federal
penitentiary yeah so now a mess would
all type of new guys ain't consistent
I still got yeah but I got la habits so
la habits are spend money like his
[ __ ] go out of style you just want a
guy who spends thousands every day yeah
so I'm still coming to that my friend oh
yeah your tip a rich guy in LA
[ __ ] rich do you give a twenty like
what I don't even want this is it
but but she moves me [ __ ] migrate you
lose your mind right and so I come here
I mean I so I get out there the next
thing you know money's starting to slow
up so now I'm like [ __ ] it I got to
start robbing people now yeah so now I'm
robbing people and not to laugh man it's
just so wild brah [ __ ] delusional
though you know I coulda came back to LA
humbled myself really talked to my guy
shame I gotta get my [ __ ] together
bought my pride wouldn't allow me yeah
just to be where I was at right so next
thing you know I end up catching a
robbery case in Columbus and so I'm
kicked out of college kicked out in a
fail I can't read you do it we either
Robert yeah yeah I got you know I'm
saying he loved his shoulder as he ran
opposed to it was definitely the bad
like so I feel bad
all right like what is this this is 2018
now I feel [ __ ] bad for doing it but
you a good robber or not I was good into
that point but yes I know but these are
like the irony of did is part of our
first time saying [ __ ] does the wrong
people so the people were supposed to go
rob they weren't there are you an
accurate he's supposed to hit the egg as
[Laughter]
well so if the people listen I'm sorry
you know this is Tina laughing not me
Mary and I'm just laughing uh I'm
laughing cuz I can laugh now at the pain
I can say you know it replaces it when
you can laugh at it later
every place you got there right I don't
know I was I was uh yeah you were
different I was out of my [ __ ] body
your mind out of my mind and so what end
up I end up getting caught for that and
I was out on bond but January 2006 when
I got arrested I was just out of my
[ __ ] mind and you know committing
more crimes because I have no money my
lady's pregnant at this time orders get
ready to be born and I'm like you know
you're going to the penitentiary and
it's like the perfect storm ever seen
that movie the perfect storm with the
Andrea Gail no and uh it's like the ship
and everything the ship it's like it
starts off at as a great plan and then
next thing you know it's just trying to
catch shrimp and it's in the middle of
like nine tidal waves and a typhoon and
it's probably called that yeah just came
I can't even imagine that at 21 at 21
you so just 21
imagine having everything at the height
of your life you lose everything put
this in context right after you lose
everything
every decision that you make is [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah well you [ __ ] think
about it
excuse my language but it's stupid yeah
and you fast yeah everyone's ignorant at
21 yes especially people you know that
if you don't have certain guidance or
you are you not really connected to the
whatever guidance you have you know yeah
I think that's good you're not connected
to goddess you have I think that that
was uh I would accurately describe me
and and from there nine months later I
ended up going to to get caught I came
down to Columbus this is a real story I
try to tell it to ESPN but they didn't
include it and as I come down to
Columbus I get off on the wrong exit
this is about three in the morning as I
get off on the exit I come to the
to stop light and I make a u-turn in the
middle of the road so I make the u-turn
it was a Home Depot parking lot as a
police officer sitting there make the
u-turn I have a ak-47 on on the
passenger side right I'm out on bond and
as he comes up to me I'll start thinking
about this episode from cops right I
have no [ __ ] clue while back yeah I'm
thinking about self when he walks up I'm
gonna pull off and from there you know I
get away so he walks upon the car and
literally I could see when he looked on
a passenger side he see the [ __ ]
rifle
so he's like nervous as [ __ ] I'll
[ __ ] speed off he's running back to
his car and I'm coming over this on his
bridge on a thing called Bryce Road I
get on on rap he's right behind me
here's a real deal I'm trying to get
away in a Hyundai Santa Fe oh yeah and
so now the next thing you know we're
running down a freeway and now we get
about four or five miles down the road
and as I get further down the road you
know I'm from I'm not from Louisiana
from Youngstown right we have [ __ ]
like buildings of [ __ ] I started to see
the woods right and so I'm thinking to
myself like you know brothers don't do
no bullets right a lot of brothers end
in the woods every time he's it's in the
wood absolutely so let me turn my ass
around so our minds around and next
thing you know they had the [ __ ]
spike strips oh wow
they busted a cop out brough I'm a cop
real cop dude gonna shoot somebody lay
the strip down you know what I'm saying
bro that's easy that's like when they
hire a dog to do the cop's job get out
there and get your neck wet yeah well
when I got when I got beautycon hood the
strips yeah I hit the strip so looks
like when they throw them it hopefully
that for being the situation get on
those [ __ ] strips are like probably
40 yards long man oh wow I'm throw them
alternate but probably twenty I would
say illegitimate twenty yards they form
up there and you can't even swerve to
get around him and they busted the tires
and the next thing you know I ended up
getting pulled over you know and easily
getting pulled over at that point and
now they took me out they roughed me up
threw me in the back of the car you know
[ __ ] and basically took me downtown and
the next thing you know I call this like
one of the
I collect my divine intervention moment
yeah I'm saying because I believe
personally had that not happened I
really believe and I know people talk
about a lot I can just see myself either
going to prison for life or being dead
yeah and yeah cuz what's next after that
when you think about the scale of
anything mm-hmm what's next after you
you know running from police and having
guns it's like there's not much else
after that bro you just you you keep on
pushing the proverbial bar until you
just [ __ ] believe that [ __ ] doesn't
stink anymore the next thing you know
you put yourself in a horrible situation
and were you grateful you think when
that happen a little bit of smart eating
I get I guarantee if you're gonna talk
to people on treatment talk to people
who got locked up even though you don't
want to admit it because it sounds crazy
you're glad you're glad that you're in a
circumstance that you can't get any way
anymore
and that was my my exact feeling I can't
get away I can't get in my way anymore
because y'all I can't get in my way if
if I do it I'm gonna [ __ ] it up yeah I
just don't have the discipline right now
and another thing that happened to me I
went to court that next week because I
was Wednesday I went the court like that
next Monday or some [ __ ]
the judge had mandated I gotta get a
mental health assessment so I've been
pushing away all this mental health
assistance in college and the pearl was
and all this other [ __ ]
she mandated I got it and I was
suffering from anxiety and depression
yeah right yeah early you know mental
health medication my first seven months
of my incarceration literally in a room
probably about the third and size a nine
before cell you lock down 23 hours on
the day you know Sam three pairs of
drawers three socks three t-shirts
saying toilet that you piss and [ __ ] in
it's the same [ __ ] that you drink water
out of yeah yeah literally Jacek basic
[ __ ] and in that process I call it like
you know like probably the most
introspective or weakening process in my
life you know there's almost like a
childhood or like an adolescence in a
weird way you know because you're very
limited there's not much you can do I
can't really
you're safe in a way you can't really
harm yourself a great way to look at it
you know read a little get a chance for
your brain to just be patient for a
minute you know you know what you do you
empty yourself because we you get caught
and this is a real experience and I've
heard more people admit to it you start
to think about everything you've done
wrong
yeah they start to like cleanse your
mind love thoughts of things to put you
in here right because there's nothing to
distract you you can't do anything to
distract yourself and I what ended up
happening was like the greatest [ __ ]
thing all of that isolation of God I
will promote this book to the day I die
a guy dropped off a book a small 70 page
recalled as a man thinketh by James
Allen the most impactful book I've ever
read in my life bar non comparison and
I'm very simple and I was asking myself
like how did you get Aires and after
reading the book [ __ ] 70 times in
that situation the book kept one show me
that thoughts or things until thought is
linked with purpose nothing intelligent
ever happen until thought is linked with
purpose nothing intelligent should ever
happen I kept on thinking myself like
what the [ __ ] does that mean at first
right what a man thinks about plants at
his brain plants is my he shall manifest
what ya can see believe in achieve and
speak up over and sure cousin so true
isn't it bro so [ __ ] true so simple
though yeah but when we grow up we think
like life is just a series of events
like random [ __ ] happens and you have no
control over it this game supreme
control over me creating my life Wow
and so I said oh I thought I was a
gangster so I responded as a gangster I
talked as a gangster but gangster [ __ ]
has consequences within the Americas
Sicily you ended up as a gangster you're
running from the police you got a case
on the seat that's you can wear get
everything you want you know San so then
I'm transition to prison at this time I
get seven and a half years yeah now I
want to take this medication I'm stable
I'm calm I'm cool like there's no
anxiety there's no like I got to get
something makes you go yeah that's
absolutely like a dirty motor a dirty
[ __ ] motor you can cook 100% you can
label with that I get to prison there's
a gentleman by the name of mr. Keller
Conte the warden of the prison
beautiful guy talked a bunch but he said
Maurice my father was a chief of Sierra
Leone for 15 years
Wow he said in Africa he said when guys
would do something wrong we'll bring him
closer to the village figure out what's
going wrong
help him out fix him back up and then
send him back out he said in America you
all throw people away he said this is
not over I don't want to throw you away
something like all right this is like
our cool I've been in my [ __ ] way to
sports right next thing you know he said
I want to put you in a bunch of
psychological social and emotional
support of course
right at this point I never heard of
[ __ ] but for those who don't know it's
therapy all they told me is like you
going to therapy but guys in prison
don't want to call it therapy you just
want to cry right yeah it's so through
the process of that I start going these
[ __ ] classes every day from like 8:00
in the morning til 12:00 and afternoon
and could you how educated were you at
this point and not judge your education
or anything but like at this point how
were you like could you read a book no
and I was gonna get into that no so I
could read the words but I probably
couldn't comprehend right right so my
talent allowed them to allow myself to
basically be pushed through school oh
yeah
tenth grade like me and Cory were laughs
and I had a 13 on my a CT and I cheated
to get into college you know I'm saying
right well I just just write it was all
the barriers weren't there there was
nothing to tell you hey look there was
no mirrors really for you it's just all
just one way signs cousin as long as you
can generate revenue on this football
field we'll find a way to get you to the
field so and did you never think is
gonna win you never think is going to
end of course no no I'm saying so we
look we literally got done with that but
then another thing happened after I was
doing that I didn't realize that that
same motivation that I had to be a great
football player was the saying like that
was an energy now inside of me just
wanted to do something phenomenal right
right so I said okay that's a great I
was gonna ask you about that yes so I
said what do you do when you want to be
on a football you go watch film from
people you want to be like so I said
okay I want to be a businessman because
there were so many entrepreneurial
things that drug dealing had gave me I
always say crime in its inception is
entrepreneurial I want to take control
of my own destiny
oh yeah drug dealer people always look
at a drug dealer like a bag I'm like
that's a bit that man is a businessman
wrong product right wrong yeah bad
product bad product but it's a B but
he's the businessman he sources product
he sells he retains customers he gives
consignment he work with logistics I
that's really you you can capital
allocation we can go on and on on a
great but but that's what he does and so
I said okay let me formally teach myself
about this so I'll start educating
myself and reading and reading so he's
go to commissary and when people would
send me money 20 $30 here I will start
to get legal pads I'm ready to do book
reports and just read from people free
from people read from people read
entrepreneur incorporate a Fast Company
Wall Street Journal New York
and how are you feeling at this point
like are you like I mean are youth that
still thinking about football at this
point are you know so I thought somehow
I was 22 and I'm at seven and a half
years would have put me out of prison
I've been 30 years old so at that point
I'm like you know I'll never play
football again
and so I was just anxious to learn
something else that I can take care of
myself with right and so through reading
I was just like yo there's a [ __ ] big
world out here you can be exciting you
can be successful anything you want
anything you want so yeah and if you
ever hear me talk always talk about
[ __ ] reading changed my life nothing
else reading changed my life it just
opened my eyes up to what was possible
what you can do how you can create your
world you can take that same work ethic
and place it elsewhere
and what about your child at this point
is your baby born yet yeah so she's born
and and she can't see her you can't see
her door isn't a shion's so what would
happen is that uh you know every
probably three months and I stopped him
from coming because it was easier to
live the life prison as if they didn't
exist so Wow so you mean you tell your
wife about that or you tell you yes
older than so it became hard so if you
came to see me it will remind me of what
I was missing
oh wow so if I see you I got to see like
[ __ ] this is a whole child she's around
me I mean she's around me in a moment
I'm visiting my emotions that I cut off
in prison this [ __ ] is like for real you
know saying like what the [ __ ] am i
doing you start to beat yourself up is
that a common practice for people that
are inmates um - or people that are
incarcerated
oh yeah you have two different extremes
some guys like a ton of visits because
they like to live in outside world right
so you know presidents like prison I
always say is the most intense
environment you can never be you know
says so just think about this right and
there's no women and it's all men the
guard women the guards are with me
sometimes you know that's gotta be that
even be worse like then I can't even get
it
this was make it we go to bed ya know
it's [ __ ] nuts man just imagine like 6
o'clock in the first of all the lights
never go out oh just imagine I said
remain college I wouldn't turn the
lights out doing if I can piss me off
bro
so you'll be pissed off laughter yeah
[ __ ] Lester's out there they call him
lit up less there but do as fluorescent
as [ __ ] bulbs all day bro bull
Bulbul bulbs and Dude Love light bulbs
on Oh then he walk in any room and he
wouldnt even in the room and just turn
on the [ __ ] lights and roll out yeah
there was something riding in his head
if he had lights on and made him feel
comfortable so he would cut him on
everywhere he went man and [ __ ] you
Lester I mean he's a nice kid but he
wasted a lot of money around America
with all this erroneous wattage bro
well prisons prison is wasting a lot of
money oh and I keep the [ __ ] lights
on all day but could you imagine 6:00 in
the morning you have to be like it's
game day every day you know it's [ __ ]
nuts bro you know it's but it's game day
you know right like just in we're not
talking about like sporadic events
you're talking about on a consistent
basis guys getting my ass kicked at 6:00
in the morning yeah you know we got into
it at recreation last night we're going
to child you get your ass kicked on the
way to child you know you talk about
[ __ ] getting you know [ __ ]
baby or you on ton hot water throwing a
face over [ __ ] card games you're
talking about [ __ ] just intense
environment all day
what were some things that you liked
about it but the one thing you like
about prison is the respect factor and
so in society if I disrespect you or you
disrespect me we can like walk away you
know our hire lawyers [ __ ] we can do
other thing in prison it is the ultimate
punishment fast so there's not know what
there's no line there's no talking
behind people's back there's no people
[ __ ] Wow
there's no stealing if you can't like
defend yourself for taking what you want
from people there's no gossiping there's
none of that and everything has a
serious demeanor people in prison
literally don't look at each other right
so I can remember like for four years
walking through prison like you don't
look at people because you don't want to
show your cards you have cards they're
in your eyes if we don't talk to each
other we don't have no business with
each other we don't even look at each
other we don't need to speak to each
other so there's a there's an organ
there's there's a sense of organization
in prison very fast fascinating there's
a sense of discipline within the within
the element are within the environment
right did you have altercations in
prison or no yeah just over but over
[ __ ] over washer you know see just
think about this right so you have a
washer and this is a serious thing like
if
allow somebody to skip you online to
wash your clothes
it could be perceivable yeah arguments
over the microwave
these are serious thing arguments over a
basketball game right and so this forces
you to defend like your space and so
prison everybody's trying to just
imagine you in a neighborhood and all
the sales are houses everybody's trying
to stake claim as to who they are at
neighborhood yeah and it's either you're
with the guys you want to populace you
know send the majority with the blood
scripts Mexican guys you know our guys
who are within a white gang and it's
there's many different factions oh
there's the you have all of that within
one housing unit and so for everybody to
coincide there has to be an extreme
amount of respect amongst each other
this is everyday bro every day you only
have three telephone it's telling it
monopoly but with knives but it sounds
like an intense so now
so you just imagine that so I've learned
click I've learned quickly when I'm here
this ain't my program right I guess
ain't my deal like you know I what I did
in the streets and what the consequences
were like yo this is not you like and so
I had to admit that to myself that I'm
not ready to die here right you know so
I'm not ready to fight over a [ __ ]
microwave I'm not ready I'm not ready to
die over a microwave right I'm not ready
to die over disrespecting prison like it
just not this is not my environment and
so you have guys like literally who
[ __ ] nuts and I can call it for what
it is these guys are [ __ ] nuts guys
were never going home so right they got
nothing to lose my sentence is seven and
a half years so my circumstances aren't
like yours because the average person in
prison who I was that these guys are
doing 15 years or better so the way they
look at what's going on what's going on
is two different things so I said Reese
your program is to get your hands in
here re-educate yourself figure out what
you're doing get the [ __ ] out of here
yes what I did and at this point when
you get out who's still there that was
there whenever like or any of the
celebrities and the stars is any of that
still no so um I give it to Mike Tomlin
to coach for our players yeah he reached
out and wrote me a letter which is
beautiful because I'm like you know you
guys are [ __ ] at that time that won
the Super Bowl and for you to think
about Maurice Clarett in [ __ ] prison
who've never I ain't gonna interfere
around four yards I thought oh just
great
and literally that was it you know but
you know it's um you start to look at it
different because you start to look at
life as you know these people don't owe
me anything they don't owe me the
personal connection and you start to
realize that your friendships are just
circumstantial right you know as long as
you're that guy entertaining or you have
a certain status amongst peers people
would love to be associated with right
when you're not that guy anymore
like there was never a human connection
or human part today you know saying and
so I can't say the same in all cases but
you're not a factor you don't help me
get [ __ ] you don't help me get in the
club you don't help me get up an
endorsement deal you don't help me to do
that so we don't hold any value right
and the only people I had in my corner
like outside of anybody or just my
mother my lady my daughter and that was
it
Brody you know I just called it for what
it is that was it yeah and so when I
when I got out of prison you know [ __ ] I
had 400 bucks
you don't said and I had bunches of
people who are and what was your
attitude like cuz would you I mean
because you had had I mean fiscally
maybe you who knows what you had and
like you're you know but you were at I
mean just yeah you were at this
superficial level of a billionaire I
mean you were so superficial billionaire
not superficial yes right like not you
personally but the you know the the
environment inside yeah in your psyche
it's like you think you're a billionaire
bro is is let me tell like this is it
was very [ __ ] humbling you know and
and what kept you like going at that
point at those moments like but to know
after from reading from people so many
success stories there wasn't a shadow of
a doubt like so if you talked to me long
enough
I even outside of this you see I got a
[ __ ] ton of confidence so hmm I just
believe like anything I'll attach myself
to our put must put my focus on and I
just really focus and I feel like I have
success I'm gonna do well with it yeah
there's not a shadow of a doubt I don't
even worry like weary or has always been
in you that's always been in you so even
from football to whatever I do I just
feel like if I focused on something I
figured out so I had read so many
success stories and just the process of
it and I'm very disciplined I got a
[ __ ] crazy work ethic these are
things that I was not in control yeah
and so I knew I would be successful in
something and the thing I wanted to be
successful in initially
what senior care services yeah and this
happened from I used to have eight
ladies likes to call my golden girls
uh-huh
these are all ladies who said we
identify with people who are
incarcerated because as our children
grow up they forget about us oh wow and
they start living families they start to
like live their lives the huge problem
in America a lot of senior citizens are
really forgotten about a lot of men up
in homes where they're not being careful
appropriately so I had people who told
me that and so they said these are just
real nice so they all said this but they
weren't from one place they were just
Ohio State fans right and Maurice
Clarett fans right as I said man this
would be a cool deal to learn it to
understand it but to provide care
transportation and so on and so forth
that was the initial thing but from
seeing so much success our reading from
so much success I was like I can
actually do this and that was my
motivation I just like I'll put myself
together at some point so I ended up
getting out of prison in 2010 and I had
an opportunity to play football for a
minor league team in Omaha Nebraska a
great [ __ ] City if anybody's never
been to Omaha and so I went up to Omaha
and I thought that Omaha was gonna be
like full of just [ __ ] cornfields and
everything else it wasn't and it was
some of the most down urban American
it's the most American place that you
can [ __ ] name and from small
businesses to people who are [ __ ]
millionaires billionaires driving pickup
trucks simple everyday [ __ ] from people
who were so successful but what Omaha
also allowed me to do was to adjust
slowly so I got out here I was able to
play football go to the gym come home
talk to my family and just do like
simple [ __ ] some safe regiment in a safe
environment safe regiment but I also
almost talk about this like this is one
of the greatest experiences and I'm all
aside from playing football when I was
in prison I had read so much from Warren
Buffett [ __ ] [ __ ] tons of information
when I went to Omaha knew Warren Buffett
was out there and things like that right
so our coach ended up being this guy by
the name of Joe Moglia Joe Mowgli had
made probably four hundred million
dollars he end up leaving as the active
CEO of TD Ameritrade ended up becoming
the other chairman of the board son of
all things he wanted to do he wanted to
get back in the culture of football he
ended up coming back to be the head
coach of our team
every Wednesday he would tell guys like
hey if you have anything that you want
to ask financially come and meet me on
Wednesday Wow
out of everybody only two of us showed
up right every week so he said [ __ ] that
I'm not about to keep on making this
available the guys had no [ __ ] clue
what he was offered valuable information
from my [ __ ] Titan right so he
said Maurice come to the golf course
with me I'm like yo bro I play golf no
I'm saying he said just come to the golf
quarters tell me a story how the [ __ ]
did you go from prisons ended up here so
I told him a whole story
after I'm done he said I've never asked
Warren for a favor in my life let me see
if I can call Warren Buffett and came to
meet you something myself like
[ __ ] I'm 18 months a person like
this [ __ ] about to meet with my
black ass you know okay so I walk into
my apartment and I serious [ __ ] no it's
true funny man so Warren Buffett a
[ __ ] right so I walked through the
[ __ ] the joint and market apartment
he hit my phone up he's like Reese he
said you know this is Warren and I'm
like oh [ __ ] you know because I and I
remember his voice distinctly Kyle used
to watch Charlie Rose in prison he still
watches [ __ ] interview everybody
right
and so the quick Charlie Rose my man
allegations it is what it is right and
so so we ended up I ended up going right
and calling him right or either calling
me I'm talking to him on the phone and
he like yo you got any think I'm doing
Saturday I'm like yo whatever going on
Saturday is canceled don't worry right
and so I'm getting my [ __ ] together I go
to TJ Maxx at the time I get like my
[ __ ] outfit I think like it's the
best thing you know I'm broke his [ __ ]
so I go over to his house I go over to
his office and ironically a person who
had a meeting before him at castle he
was like yo do you want to hang out and
I'm like you serious and I'm like yeah
he like you wanna hang out so he's
sitting there one-on-one for five hours
right and so I'm asking to do everything
ever like [ __ ] dreamed of and it was
like cool [ __ ] that happened was he
preaching at you or was he cool to talk
to when I do this do so he reads a
[ __ ] ton
so it's easy for him to have a
thoughtful intellectual personal
conversation this one Saturday this do
is more [ __ ] humble and down-to-earth
than anybody I've ever [ __ ] met right
this dude controls [ __ ] [ __ ] son of a
yeah did you think about even asking him
for like a million I would have and I
would have called it a small million let
me get a small million yeah but I'm
telling this dude was just like he was
like [ __ ] he was he was zoned in you
know saying and uh and so the next thing
you know we end up meeting and getting
together and I had and I ended the
meeting and [ __ ] was like you know I
know you got better [ __ ] to do and talk
to me
right right and run the world and next
thing you know I rolled out to UM
excuse me my rollabout rolled up back
home a few months after that ESPN that
reached out to me and he said hey can we
do a 30 for 30 million Jeff so and after
that took about eight months to shoot
the show and I woke up one day after the
show came out and I had eleven hundred
and I remember literally eleven hundred
emails from people just seated talking
and asked him to come and speak and it
never I've never done public speaking
prior to that and I ended up just going
on the road and start to tell my story
and ask questions and answer questions
and from there I ended up getting into
the transportation business because I
got tired of it literally felt as I was
traveling and I'm pretty short about
he's traveled a lot you can feel lonely
yes as cool as it may look to the
outside oh it's long yep you're in a
hotel by yourself you go your spectacle
wants to be on stage yeah after you get
off stage you're taking a picture you're
talking hands and next thing you know
you think about what other City going
through next right so I had done about
350 speaking engagements in three years
which is a [ __ ] ton you don't say yeah
after why I feel like you just repeating
words and I was like okay let me get
into another business because I don't
want to depend on this my whole life
like I get for somebody to book me for
an engagement right right and so from
there I'm getting the transportation and
after transportation was doing what it
did for a couple years I ended up going
to an event in Ohio
and I was I was doing the event and
through the process of doing event the
event had ended and there was a person a
gentleman who had been teaching some
young men over like 17 or 18 years old
so I'm gonna work that we had done in
prison and I was like yo my man like
where did you get this stuff from it was
cognitive behavioral therapy it was an
exercise with activate an event the mind
activity two body reaction the
consequence and this was stuff that I
had helped to facilitate in prison Wow
it's one of the things they teach you in
licensed clinical social work it's one
of the things they teach in the first
year it's like one of the CBT yes sir
yes sir and what ended up happening was
that I just like enjoying what he was
talking about was like you know what do
you do he was like you know I run a
behavior HOF agency and I said what the
[ __ ] is a behavior health agency he was
like I work with mental health and drug
and alcohol and for me having so many
issues with drug they're like this is my
yeah that's my home this is my home
but even going through that work in
prison
I felt that out of everything that was
helping to rehabilitate guys the actual
work the social work right the
therapeutic services or the things that
guys would come back to the block and
talk about and have intellectual
discussions or guys would become
revealing about themselves on in a
therapeutic format and I thought to
myself like more kids and the Intercity
need to basically be and be involved and
connected with this right so I went
through like an 8 month process of
policies and procedures we go through
that whole deal in the process of doing
that end up open up our company called
the red zone and at first we went back
to literally inner cities and I thought
that there was so much emotionally like
I was thinking about to my childhood the
amount of murders I had seen yeah
domestic violence of robberies and just
the amount of trauma that I had been
experienced that I never process right I
never emotionally got over it right I
was functioning from like a space of
fear or where the drugs and alcohol
masked like some my childhood [ __ ] oh
yeah yeah you keep it inside of you and
did you your father wasn't present when
you were growing up no you know so I was
born in 83 and my mother divorced in 84
I say yeah and so like my mother never
down talked him or me about to be a bad
person but just through their disconnect
well yeah there just wasn't any male
involvement so my mother worked as a
second year educational coordinator our
medical school so she worked 45 minutes
away so as a result from that kids a lot
home alone a lot yeah so now the
neighborhood in the environment raises
us to raise you yeah and so how I found
I mean obviously I've known about you
right and a lot of people like when I
said Marie
that's gonna come on the podcast you
know I listen to his podcast business
and biceps you and Cory and John and
it's um it's a great hang it's like uh
if it you know if I recommend checking
out their podcast because it's a fun
it's like I don't know what it is I
can't feel like I can't feel if I feel
like I'm at the gym or the office or the
therapist that's what I can't tell when
but that's what I like about but I'm
glad you feel that because that's the
intention and it's exactly what I feel
it's like there's a moment or it's like
okay this is uplifting and this is
inspiring and then there's moments where
it's like it's just guys like joking
around it feels like a fantasy football
league and then it's there's moments
where it's like you know the other day
you guys were talking about loyalty and
stuff like that and even if I don't
resonate with everything that's said on
the podcast and we're gonna have Cory
and John in in just a few minutes even
if I don't resonate with everything
there's just every one that makes me
think of something like all loyalty
makes me just hearing about loyalty
makes me think of well you know let me
think back into my life
loyalty if I were to go back and make a
list of who's been loyal to me in my
life it's just you know it's fun to hear
um just things that you hear you're then
inspired to think about yes but I think
one of the biggest things we talked
about this last night at dinner and what
the focal point even is just to bring
like real things that you feel yeah I'm
a real big field person yeah yeah if you
if you don't fill it as you're saying it
it's not real entertainment right and
and when we talk about business and you
talk about growing business from from
from our business standpoint we try to
talk about things that are actually real
and not like the cute pictures and
videos and [ __ ] [ __ ] music on
Instagram that like misleads kids you
know cynical 100% especially young kids
yes but you and so you could be mislead
so if you've given me your time a
[ __ ] hour just think about this right
so people are giving you an hour of
their [ __ ] day or 40 minutes for 30
minutes or however long the format is
right you kind of owe it to them if they
believe in you and they're giving your
ear to be thoughtful and peer mature
entertainment yeah to give a message
that's real yeah and so that way like at
the Cordova saw heard didn't say I'll
say this on
Charlie Rose he said from the specific
comes a universal so if you can connect
to yourself and get down to specific
emotion I'm pretty sure that may work in
comedy right yes going from something I
don't give a [ __ ] like you're drawing
from something I saw it connects to
people because you like oh I feel that I
can laugh right yeah
disconnect somewhere and so the park has
is a format of things that like I've
actually been through things that we
actually experience yeah and and and
having a level of entertainment that
doesn't seem cheesy phony are like
commercial yeah I'm saying and but but
that's real
yeah and I'm saying and so like you have
you also have an element to where people
who have come from humble beginnings you
know saying Corey literally comes from
the trailer parks John comes from a poor
background in Chicago ya know very I
come from the hood and [ __ ] Youngstown
yeah and it's a great voice that's out
there I mean that's one of the things
that I really like about about you guys
cast is that yeah it connects I like
that it's the Midwest you know it's hard
working you know our producer Nick is
from Wisconsin it's like and he's one of
the hardest workers I know it's like you
know it's a voice that's that's not out
there as much these days I feel like or
that you can't find on the coast anyway
and so it's you know that's what I
really love listening about it I got a
couple more questions for you and then
we're gonna we're gonna take a break for
a few minutes and get Cory and John and
you and we're gonna do another hour with
the guys and some listener questions as
well oh yeah we got some listeners and
questions as well I just want to ask you
this do you do you feel like uh do you
feel like you were always going to be do
you feel like if football was supposed
to be your thing or do you feel like
that you were always gonna be good at
something I don't know if that's a wild
question or no it's not um I don't think
when I was young I think football when I
was young was a way to fit in and grab
friends right yeah I think I didn't
necessarily like football like to work
hard right and I also looked at football
as a vehicle to get out of my situation
right when I didn't love football didn't
love it at all
I loved the element of competing but not
oh yeah as much as that and the older I
get and I started to realize that the
science of working hard and
understanding what you're working
towards and being clear at that I have a
confidence not some arrogant but I've
none of that you've already I can be
successful yeah whatever it is I choose
to put my attention to and so I don't
know if that answers the question but I
still feel like I'll be great at
something because I know how to just
like connect with my feelings and I know
anything about me may be connected to
will be connected to what's real and not
even a commercial success like you know
I'll be successful just because I'll be
doing [ __ ] that makes me happy that's
right yeah like as corny and cliche as
may sound but this like sitting down
makes me happy ya talkin to oh I can
tell man look when I was watching 34:30
I mean I was I mean I was teared up at
one point like just seeing you like you
know you could just kind of tell I don't
know just say you were just a really
deep person emotionally you know yeah
and that and I'm that I'm that same way
you know and I noticed when I'm growing
up if I didn't have like somebody to
tell me it was okay to be that way then
it's like I was always didn't know what
was going on with my emotions you know
absolutely and so then you have this
whole life where you have these emotions
but you don't know if it's even okay to
think about them or how to feel or so
but just imagine you pioneer in a space
for that to be cool right yeah right so
so now if I look up to you if I look at
the more recent look up to anybody now
this guy talking about it now like this
is a real thing
yeah now this is it's cool to be
indifferent about my emotions it's cool
to be not cool but being sad is normal
being confused as normal having anxiety
is normal right
Oh feeling indifferent about different
things right and so even as you say that
it just it just affirms and gives
confirmation that that's the role to
keep wanting to travel because there's
more people who [ __ ] putting your
voice in the ear on a consistent basis
who needs that
yeah and that helps them to heal or to
be whole as they're moving forward oh
it's a good it's an amazing gift man I
mean it's I think you have that I think
really feel like you have that gift I
like it to a remarkable level of anybody
that I've you know listened to or heard
or yeah I don't know I just have this
like you just have an uncanny ability to
iterate comfortably to others like kind
of how you feel and then also how it
kind of fits into what you're doing yeah
you know because sometimes it's so hard
to connect those two you know it's so
hard to connect this to and still stay
confident in and moving forward you know
I did it yeah but I don't know um do you
feel like that's a blessing do you feel
I get to learn things I don't I think so
learn from experience but I believe it's
a blessing because it allows me to walk
as a whole person everywhere I go yeah
and I don't have to bring a
representative I don't have to like I
get to I get I get to be me you know
like like um if I was if I would did
this podcast ten years ago I would say
man I care about my genes what my shoe
is gonna look like
yeah I'm gonna fight all the Red Hot
Chili Peppers sure they know what they
are I know I like the shirt I'm saying
farmers Martin got on $30 Levi we got
Red Hot Chili Peppers I just got this
plant I feel you and I don't this is I
honestly this is the most dressed up
I've got because I honestly I was so
excited about you guys coming in I
appreciate well I appreciate but I feel
ya just feel yeah like I listen to you
and I feel like you really embody a lot
of what we want you know like what we
try to do here you know we got a lot a
lot of our listeners or young men that
have struggled you know and then should
you know have struggled to you know
being raised by single parents that sort
of thing and and yeah I'm just I'm glad
that to be able to help turn some of our
listeners on you guys podcast because I
think that there's a you know you guys
have a wealth of knowledge in a fun way
and emotional knowledge to offer people
magic no I wa even so they gave me when
they told me who you were before I
purposely did not look at you because I
said okay I looked at something Raji and
I said okay I don't want to form an
opinion of somebody yeah and then but
because you want to like you want to go
and have like the natural energy of
something and even through talking you
could tell us something as for as you
can tell energy and you can tell if it
isn't right but when I was on the plane
yesterday I was coming down I don't know
where the [ __ ] we were at
man everything feels right right I say
you know I just stuff feels right yeah
like oh yeah a hundred percent things
feel right but not only feel right and
you know we talked about this at dinner
like I know why they feel right and I
know how you can push the gas for things
to get better than what they are look
better what they are and if anybody like
has ever felt that feeling that's like a
beautiful feeling to have yeah and to
know you yourself I'm not drinking
drugging I'm not [ __ ] being a bad
towards my woman I'm not right I can
sleeping around I'm great to the guys
and we have a good relationship powerful
huh you feel coming from and and the
stuff that we're talking about the stuff
that you can like actually say this is
what I do and the preservation of that
in a in a society right now where so
much is driven off side of let me look
cool and let me promote what's fake I
think that even you we owe it to people
to provide platforms and be like okay
like humanity still does exist yeah
right that's it yeah no I get that uh
there's something about you you don't
sit you almost defame you don't like to
be the center of attention in a weird
way or you get or the feet the way it
makes you feel doesn't land super well
inside of you just the center of
attention is too much too much
responsibility my my you know and and
and I would be the center of attention
if it was simple right you know and that
thing but sometimes but a lot comes with
a center of attention
yeah because you're holed out yeah you
know say yeah you become a [ __ ] and you
can get involved in things that
financially makes sense or look cool but
just may not be you yeah I'm sad and I
don't want to be anybody's [ __ ] I don't
want to be a product [ __ ] or I don't
want to be a system [ __ ] I don't want
to be standing next to people if I
really don't like you and I really don't
believe what you value I really don't
want to be around you like and not from
a hateful stamp right I just don't want
to affiliate my being what you're being
right and it's bad magnets right there
but but I think that but but that comes
back to understanding why I love myself
and I love myself from like I do right
by my family can you feel you can you
feel is it easier to feel loved now as
an adult than it wasn't your young 100%
but I think that I think it starts with
self though you know cuz now I love
myself and I know who really loves me
and and I could I could just tell like
is this a marketing relationship is this
a you need something I can identify that
clearly now right and and is is
beautiful to have somebody to love you
for you I'm talking about my woman I'm
talking about my mother
I'm talking about my daughter I'm even
talking about what Cory and John and I
think that I like I can give you one
thing about John right so this is John
Fossey he'll be in here in just a couple
minutes another chump in Tibet they're
watching on the light so just think
about this right so we were getting
ready to do a show that was revolved
around sports okay and then John goes
and watches he watches the thirty four
thirty and after he watches the thirty
four thirty and the sporting show that
we were going to do was a little bit
more hardcore and languages file and all
this other [ __ ] right
and so after watching the show he had
come back to Cory and say yo I don't
really think that that direction that
serves him well to put him in that light
based upon the amount of kids and people
that he deals with yeah and so to have
that amount of consideration right and
doing that so Cory knew me already a man
Cory have been buddies [ __ ] eight
nine ten years or however long we've
known each other right
and so Cory already had like a level of
light you know our connection but for
John to step in and do that without even
knowing me right to recognize that in
advance to recognize the Valiants yes
and it just it just spoke to a lot about
that so like you kind of know who you're
around yeah you know what like what's up
with the people around you so when you
can do that and you can [ __ ] sit and
have a good meal and you can talk and
you can [ __ ] and when you get to the
airport you laugh and like little kids
because you're happy that it feels like
a team is going somewhere yeah to do
something that's fun huh
bro it's like that's what you miss
probably votes about the sports I bet
this camaraderie there's nothing like a
brotherhood bro there's nothing like you
and a group of guys who have a common
interest and you all working towards
something and shit's starting to go
right and you figure [ __ ] out and you
have a fun team it you get it looking
about this you get an energized off of
ideas yeah oh yeah that's not that's not
the cool [ __ ] Bentley in the cute
music
and all the [ __ ] filters like you
getting inspired from talking about an
idea and like what this could become
that's like [ __ ] dream and that's
like you know that has nothing to do
with nothing else other than creative
thought it does have two women and
[ __ ] fake titties and ass shots and
all that stupid [ __ ] like you know
there's it's real
there's I just think about how you may
get excited about somebody who may comes
on to your show you think in work at
this girl who could we affect how they
receive this what our comments looking
like that I gave my all to the show that
is beautiful bro oh it's a fear it's a
real feel it's visceral you get it in
your body in your chest it runs up my
neck I can feel when when things are
when it's real maybe you know then what
you done you like this is work well done
you go to sleep satisfied yes cause
you're not cheating anybody you're not
you're putting something good out into
the world you're being rewarded for it
yes sir and uh yeah it's it is a really
different and comfort witness to sleep
yeah I remember when I would go into a
meetings one of the best times I ever
had and still have har I remember
sitting down between two guys that I
knew in meetings from meetings and I sat
there and they were both laugh when were
joking around and I was like man this is
interesting all I really wanted and I
was just started tearing up I was like
all I wanted my whole life really was
just a sit around and joke with with
with guys and I've been chasing these
other things that it maybe try to fill
whatever this little feeling is right
here just to be in a little group and
have fun you know like I've been chasing
this out you know or you know you think
about other stuff or do other things
like you're saying you go after like the
shiny trinkets you know but you but I
was like man it just I don't know just
to have some sort of a little bit of a
brother I was about to pass the
brotherhood what is it else that you
think that you're getting from that
moment it was nice to know that these
people cared about me because we'd all
agreed to meet there and we all showed
up and so like they cared you know and I
knew they cared about me and so that
made me feel when I knew somebody else
cared about me it made me feel good I
sew sew sew their arm and and it this is
one thing I like about meetings right it
allows me to comfortably put my
vulnerabilities in front of people yeah
coming fro yeah yeah hundred percent
yeah yeah I know I could talk to them
and say anything to them yes I don't
know there was just something about
being flanked by two people that I knew
we're like we're like almost like
brothers you know yes
it just felt uh like a childlike love
yes that's what it felt like it felt
like something I've never really had
that I've been wanting my whole life so
I guess the question like so when we see
people are are more people you know cuz
like you like I always say it but like
you weren't birthed out of your mother's
[ __ ] become an abuser of drugs are
colic you know and you're chasing a
filling right now so I'm real big into
feel yeah that's what I'm into man and
that's one that when I saw I was just
like man we I would we have got to have
Maurice Clarett and I'm just so excited
and and then when I've got turned on to
the podcast even more I'm like oh this
is great this is a this is like a fun
goofy educational but also heartfelt
place where I can hang out um let's get
the guys in here and then we'll go to
the video questions didn't do that then
okay they're party very specific they
are yeah um let's rattle off one or two
we'll just make it a long episode yeah
yeah I was I you know those guys I was
like will still do a full hour with you
oh yeah definitely I'll place to go we
have nothing
oh yeah yeah so great we're not gonna be
cutting it short at all I have a couple
quick ones
when you had your cops chase yes I might
against embedded tell did you have a
katana in the car a katana blade like a
blade a big sword
oh no no so here's the thing there was a
hatchet in the car already know so it
was like a [ __ ] it was like a it was
like a [ __ ] you know like meat
cleaver hey Paul Bunyan dealership no it
was my it was my uncle's car yeah like a
[ __ ] like a little tuna to use for
the yard I I did have four guns don't
have four have four good you were gonna
need the hatchet don't you know that's a
more logical weapon but and here's a
hero and one more in prison before you
realize that like that wasn't for you
and you were talking about their
scuffles all-time like I'm sure there's
gangs and stuff but we're people [ __ ]
with you because most I'm sure why not
so no dude there was Michigan
there was no there was [ __ ] talking but
the in prison is also an environment
that is very clear it's either you into
the [ __ ] or you out of the [ __ ] right
and it was clear that I was out of the
[ __ ] you know I'm said and so even as
you walk around I'm not being boastful
for myself but there's a lot of tough
guys in prison but I'm not a [ __ ]
myself right you know said and so you
walk around with a demeanor and your
demeanor is like whatever is whatever
you know rather [ __ ] want to
fight rather you want to do whatever and
so guys can feel it on you you know it's
an aura like and you didn't have it
you're like yeah I'm not a chump you
know I'm saying on any level but I'm not
the toughest guy in prison and I and I
humbly say that because there's a
anybody you know who really runs a
prisoner Mexicans
you know Mexicans Mexicans run America
these days that's the guy who has the
power is the guy who is willing to take
it to furthest these guys these Mexican
guys imprison us based upon what were
they from they don't care about that
yeah they're ready to go to heaven bro
they don't these dudes do not give a
[ __ ] about dying I give a [ __ ] about
dying that's it that's the finish line
I'm 50 pounds lighter than you I'm not
fighting you I'm gonna stab you yeah I'm
cool yeah my boundaries in you win
that's it yeah a lot of a lot of guys
have just like so many like the tattoo
the rosary they're already they almost
look like a funeral tattooed on their
chest like you got your whole family
standing around a casket on your chest
it's a wrap let's get one of these video
questions real fast and then what's up
to Maurice I'm a big fan of both of you
guys and I've been watching this past
weekend since the beginning and I've
decided to call him for a question or
video and a question and so my question
for Maurice is what led to you I'm
choosing Ohio State to play football and
is there any advice you'd give me as a
running back when picking what schools
I'd like to go to so thank you both and
you know of a good day yeah well I'll
state didn't offer me a scholarship I
decided to go to our state and told them
I was coming and and that was it I knew
I want to go to Hollis Tate I knew the
guys who were there they weren't better
than me you know I was a lot more
arrogant then and uh I think you have to
be arrogant and decisive within your
decision-making to understand four guys
better than you or not and go or you
feel that you want to go not where you
feel like maybe cool there's a lot of
young guys who go to schools because I
think the school is cool yeah but it
isn't a good fit for their skillset you
know it's understanding your skill set
but the biggest thing I could give
advice to the guys understand your skill
set what do I do well and does that
translate to this environment right here
right and glad that's a business yes yes
so I understood it very well my skill
set and what I did and then I looked at
their office and it was the same thing
and I went to go meet the guys and I
went to these guys and I Mike Tyson's my
greatest person I want to meet Emma Jim
Carrey if I can meet Jim Carrey and sit
down a halftime with Mike Tyson I think
that I'll be like some of the coolest
[ __ ] and literally that's what happened
I just was like you know I'm taking
y'all [ __ ]
and so Mike Tyson used to talk about the
art of skullduggery and he said you know
uh guys are they're very easy to compete
behind each other's back but there's a
different sort of reverence that you
have when you tell a guy I'm taking a
[ __ ] right you know saying it so now it
becomes like I'm about to work my ass
off and do you have that same deal and I
knew that they didn't and that's
basically how I became you got Mexican
right there I got Mexican I was really I
was wanna die in that instance in that
vibe you're like this is what I'm
putting on the line is that I'm gonna do
this is as far as I'm gonna go can you
match it but so same thing that you do
same thing that you do in your industry
yeah [ __ ] I got this yeah I'm
gonna take you to a place that I know
that you can't I'm gonna take I always
call it taking [ __ ] to the
middle ocean let's see yeah you either
going down to water or are we gonna get
to shore I love that man and yeah the
other questions I think the other guys
would have some good input you called
they were specifically for years okay
great cool awesome race correct clorets
so excited uh so grateful that you guys
have come out we'll be right back
we'll be right back with the other guys
from Bob Business of myself this is
about yes sir yeah we just had Maurice
Clarett in and he is gonna stay in
studio and joining us is going to be the
business and biceps guys the other
gentleman from his podcast and if you
want to join something you can join
Skillshare com and you can join a
classroom skill shared comm it's a place
where you can you know take any class
you want you don't want to drive across
town and park and get a backpack and get
a capri-sun and call your mom and ever
make you a lunch and then get beat up at
recess do you well now you don't have to
but you can still learn skills share is
an online learning platform over 20,000
classes in business design technology
photography or photography creative
writing data science man there's
everything you can learn how to make
trap music you can learn how to produce
music you can you can do anything
everything
think of something go learn it and our
listeners will get two months of
Skillshare for just 99 cents that's
right Skillshare is offering this past
weekend listeners two months of
unlimited access to over 20,000 classes
for just 99 cents to sign up go to
Skillshare comm slash Theo th EO that
Skillshare comm slash Theo this episode
is also brought to you by Squarespace
from websites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business quit running your
business just in the real world run it
online as well and run it with
Squarespace Squarespace has beautiful
designer templates that make it make it
make your appearance creative and give
you a powerful online identity you can
create a beautiful website with
squarespace's all-in-one platform
everything from domains websites online
stores and marketing tools if you have a
domain somewhere else you can bring it
over to Squarespace that's easy its
award-winning 24/7 customer service may
said exactly what you want it's simple
to setup it's simple so head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch your new
site or new store or new online presence
just go to squarespace.com slash Theo
von th EO vo in to save 10% off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
the squarespace.com slash Theo von for
10% off joining us now in studio with
Maurice is Corey G and John Fosco and
this is uh this is the three of them
together make up the podcast business
and biceps we are here you want to
introduce your squad uh your partner
sorry yes yes we are squad well on the
show Rick coming from yeah are you going
good there yeah so so yes he has a new
shoes on today well not the morons
joints he had on yes so mom a man
helling all the way from the Windy City
six foot two he had a sit in first class
to stretch his legs out of the way here
[Laughter]
this room takes off rip to the ball my
man all the way from the Windy City the
one and only who always wears his
sunglasses day and a night in the gym I
did request the glasses that Dottie
fosco and his ten and his tag-team
partner and his tag-team partner the
only guy I know who eats [ __ ] chicken
no not chicken cuz he says steak the
only guy I know
white steak they call it some people
yeah oh no who won't [ __ ] go to the
Doubletree and eat a [ __ ] cookie when
he goes yeah it's true the only guy I've
know who is disciplined to the bone and
regimented hailing respectfully and he
talks about it all the way from the
valley
mr. Cory G yo yo yo thanks Maurice for a
white guy see ya well it's funny I
sometimes I get called oh and this is
the this is these you got started
business and biceps right and then
brought Maurice in how did that work out
yeah we was rolling for a while about
100 shows Johnny I think about 80 shows
yeah yeah and then we were gonna bring
Moe in for a sports podcast right and I
didn't I didn't know Moe well and it was
crazy we recorded like the pilot of the
sports podcast and it was a really raw
podcast a lot of swearing not that we
don't swear now we swear Tunstall it's a
little sweaty
yeah it's very sweaty but basically
after we did it the night we [ __ ] did
it
most 34:30 came on and I had never seen
it I had never seen it and I called
Corey after I watched it and I said
Corey I don't know more well but if I'm
if I'm gonna take in a partner we're
gonna take in a partner um I don't feel
comfortable as an individual bringing
him into this platform I just don't feel
it's right I think he can offer a lot on
business and biceps because we're trying
to motivate and we're trying to talk
about overcoming struggles and my god
you know what I just saw was you know
touched me yeah so I you know Corey was
like man yeah I mean I think me and mode
been boys for a while so it was like I
said yeah absolutely I'd love to bring
him into that space you know we were
just we wanted to do something with him
we had already had a show that was
starting to chart and do well so but
open arms I was like of course most
personal development and the stuff that
he's been through alongside us is now
morphed into it you know a top 5 show
yeah and it was it interesting like or
was it tough is it tough of a friending
and I noticed this even a moun walk out
here in Los Angeles it's tough sometimes
but friending somebody that has like a
name that precedes them so what was that
like for you whenever like you
befriended mo like because sometimes
it's like you'll feel a connection to
somebody and you're not you don't care
what they do or what you know mean
you're intrigued by them you're
interested but when somebody has a name
that precedes them it's hard sometimes
- - how did you have trouble managing
your genuineness or I'm not putting on
the spot I'm just no I think this would
be great for moe to answer actually
because when we when we connected mode
just come back to Ohio and I had a
business that was doing really well in
the sports supplement space and I told
Moe like I was working with huge
athletes and some pretty heavy piece
Sterling's sharp yeah way bigger than
him so I was like so I was like you know
what I was like Moe here's the deal we
have a four M crew I asked moe to come
to the gym workout I said man I don't
really need nothin from you but what
you're gonna get when you mess with me
is I'm never gonna miss workouts I'm
gonna be disciplined I'm about my
business and but I don't need anything
from you right I don't need to I'm not
trying to get into the club and rep you
I'm not trying to get a cute video on
Instagram I don't need any stuff over my
guns across yeah yeah you know so I was
like but I got a positive environment if
you if you're trying to get down with it
then you should come on over to old
school gym [ __ ] and you felt
that huh yeah and I think that's - I
think that was like highly important
where you could just go be yourself and
I think we talked about earlier just we
want to be yourself somewhere and just
be a guy yeah and I may not think that
that was uh that was cool and nothing
about our relationship we didn't gain
anything from being around each other
yeah but in like okay let's connect and
go do this deal let's connect to go do
that deal let's connect and show a
picture and it makes one of us cooler
and I think that that was the the
original apartment and also I think that
even when we start doing the first few
episodes I think that there was just a
natural feeling yeah you know it wasn't
nothing like you know like most times
you get together with people side yo
let's outline the business and you worry
about everything but the actual thing of
what you're doing and I think that we
did more doing of the show and talking
as episode I think it felt right but I
think also if you can ask these guys I
think it was something therapeutic about
it oh wow really yeah definitely because
we were doing it for the right reason we
didn't have a business model we were
just literally John and I when we
started it we were having these amazing
conversations that I know all these
young people would be down trying to be
a fly on the wall like we should record
you have MOTU it on top of it it's
shutting it down right because now you
have there's there's the race factor
there's the culture factor there's all
these things that nothing's off balance
and we can hit off every demo it's great
ma'am oh so necessary right now I think
- especially with a lot of like you know
there's a lot more like young black men
who are having opportunities these days
and do you guys see that in in Ohio as
much like these days like is it
different than when you were growing up
do you find but I think just just what
any young person now I think to access
to information in the wanting to sort of
take control your own destiny and be an
entrepreneur there are things that I
major I think that that's more its
accessible I think with young people
like okay so they see Theo von right
they see you on Netflix they see your
podcast and they may see what other
people do and they're like I want that
right but they don't understand and I
don't even know your history what the
[ __ ] you went through to get to that
chair right now right and they don't
want to know the process what Theo has
right and what we're trying to do is say
dudes settle the [ __ ] down take pride
and sweeping the floor and say I'm on my
way up yeah don't think you're gonna be
driving a Bentley in two years [ __ ] it's
not the truth but that's not having that
way every time John talks I feel like
I'm at WWE anyway it's really straight
down the middle bro listen to an episode
last night man I got some hellofresh you
know cuz they're um don't even sponsor
of ours yet but or they are a sponsor
now I was excited I'm making some
hellofresh you know I'm listen to an
episode in the kitchen and I felt here's
what I noticed I felt better at the end
of the episode I felt like I just had a
good time you know I felt like it was
you guys were talking about loyalty and
you know and loyalty and how you how you
know where loyalty is and and and how
you recognize it like and how you treat
loyalty and how you treat your friends
and business associates and stuff and
but then also there was like you know
people screwin around
and it's just like a little bit of
everything before I knew it was over and
I was like oh this is this is cool it's
like half entertainment we've added that
because we're having so much fun now but
also giving people real applicable
information because everybody thinks
they can get a laptop and go to
Starbucks now they're an entrepreneur oh
yeah when I started my gym when I was 20
like my friends tried to have an
intervention with me because they
thought I was like [ __ ] crazy and you
know coming father you know yeah they're
like wait a second you know and so it's
like they were trippin like you ain't
drinking with us all Wednesdays no more
and I'm like mother [ __ ] I'm trying to
open a gym like you so is one of those
things where it just wasn't as cool as
they're accepted now it is looked upon
almost like an athlete or something to
that level
Oh entrepreneurship absolutely
absolutely to some degree it's way more
popular than ever there's so many fake
[ __ ] pockets dude and yes what
gets me fired up it's like okay so we
don't need to do a podcast is it a
profitable endeavor sure we do other
businesses and we do a podcast to
literally try to give him fried dude I
don't go to college you didn't go to
college right mo did mo try random
[ __ ] touchdowns right but it's like
we're trying to help people because like
success doesn't happen dude right you
got to make it happen and these kids
don't know that they they're told okay
you go to high school you go to college
you did it what if what if I don't want
to like no one says like it's okay if
you don't want to yeah what do you want
to do right [ __ ] go follow it
but but but but that's not safe right
because then otherwise then you just get
the feeling as a kid oh if I don't go to
college and I'm a failure there that's
what the other side of that
teeter-totter yeah it's like oh you're
gonna be a bomb it's like come on man
and we're here to dispel that and
there's nothing against College you know
if you want to be a doctor an engineer a
lawyer shirt you have to go there but if
you love something don't tell yourself
it can't be a career yeah cuz you're
[ __ ] lying to yourself yeah and
you're hearing your brother
you're hearing your uncle you're hearing
your parents who are all afraid afraid
to take the chance that you are about to
take yeah and you're gonna let them take
you but [ __ ] that yeah you guys are
never go on no but I just think even
even to add to that point but
I feel like I'm on you guys a spot you
are morphed into my you are now in
business and biceps Theo I love this but
I just imagine like there's there's
conversation there's processes and
systems that have to be built to build
your own career yeah and to what John
was saying people just want to jump
towards the end result to be where
you're at but nobody talks about all the
production I took place when we had to
walk out the room to break to the
segment nobody talks about the cameras
nobody talks about the hard work nobody
talks about the actual things but how
you feel during those processes and the
things that you have to do to make that
thing a reality right and that
conversation needs to be had because
it's not had in the class form or if it
is in the classroom it's inaccurate as
to what's currently taking place and I
think that if we provide that
information that a kid can come back and
say you know what
I spent my hour listening to you all I
got something out of this [ __ ] and you
can kind of go through all the titles
and find out where you're currently at
in your process you know Sam like
library the other one we have managed
your dick right when you're successful
managing you Nick is a book latest
episode the guy with the megaphone in
WWE back in the day like right next to
my name Jim what's his name Jimmy Hart
the hit Jim Cornette or the Hitman Hart
or Hart maybe Wow well Bobby the brain
Heenan is another euphemism for your
penis yeah so anyway but no I I um yeah
I didn't click on that episode
let me think I've listened to four
episodes but but yeah I just love the
camaraderie man I'm so grateful that you
guys are here what do you guys feel like
do you notice like a like a vibe in your
own come
unity from the podcast like that's what
I start to wonder what's it like there
bye you guys were talking about this
yesterday was crazy as so we have
employees and now listen to the podcast
so they they know how we think right so
we've broken a lot of employees mentally
unfortunately by absolutely doing
nothing right so they get it in their
head that were these guys on the podcast
and they said oh [ __ ] I messed this
little thing up I'm gonna get the John
from the podcast or I'm gonna get the
Cory and they get in their own heads and
like we start losing labor and we're
like brother no this is that that that's
a show and yes we teach but we've lost
people actually because they're like man
they're so regimented and they're
thinking I don't want to get in that
line of fire right you know I'm saying
so it's had it's had kind of a weird
effect but there's there's respect for
people from the outside people who don't
work for us but it's had a weird effect
with employees yeah I think online just
the overarching thing of we're here to
teach and give back we've all been
successful in our own regards we're all
pushing for more success but
understanding of what's happening in
entrepreneurship right now and how fake
is [ __ ] it that it is yeah and now
we're coming straight down the middle so
often and that they can take it out and
apply it and then when it works the
right in your dm's like yo bro that [ __ ]
was [ __ ] real I went and did this
like you know it's just those things
right there are worth it all there's no
monetary value to that bro you're
literally I was a gold as a gold gym
that they trained and aim people were
coming up showing love dude Podcast
Bubba and a three out of four guys is
like I'm here to see Theo von all that
dude so funny like you know I'm saying
so it's like the the podcast community
is just it's cool to bring these two
worlds kind of together Theo so I
commend you you know for like being open
to that I think it's awesome ya know
well look a lot of a lot of our
listeners are you know in the Midwest
and in rural communities and I don't
consider you know where you guys are
from a rural community at all but you
know I it's it's nice to know that it's
it when I'm listening and I'm feeling
inspired you know from a place that's a
little bit more connected to America
then I feel like the environment I live
you know it's just uh it's cool for me I
I think real quick on the camaraderie
like one main point is I think it's so
hard to trust three people like all the
way to the core and have that loyalty
and that's why you can hear us hit like
hard points and then have fun with it
because you know you may have a business
partner but like you ain't down with
them like you would trust him when your
back was turned if some [ __ ] was going
down but like the three of us we don't
need each other right because we don't
need each other
everything we do is pure and right
because it's pure it could be serious as
[ __ ] but then it could be fun and it's
like we don't need each other yeah so
it's just [ __ ] what it is right you
know no I love that I mean that's one
thing that podcasting is given even me
as an entertainer just freedom you know
the freedom that really to not live in
some of these bounds of this
entertainment industry but to be myself
you know it's like no rules homie yeah
and that's and then people love that you
know people absolutely love it but
nothing does - I think it's one of the
greatest things about it is that these
podcasts is broken across all barriers
all ethnicities all boundaries of
subjects titles everything and now you
have a platform to see the person yeah
and to fall in love with the person I
think that that is what we bring to that
always in my mind I think it's called
business biceps and culture because I
really believe that I've loved some of
the racial conversations that we had
yeah
that I know you couldn't get anywhere I
love just the back door of the business
conversations I love just just to
camaraderie amongst people and I just
believe that that is like something that
if even if I just don't know even if I'm
the only one cares about it I feel like
that's our gift to people you know I'm
saying absolutely yeah
when you're his brother came in and we
talked to his brother after the show
he's like you don't get it like in our
community we don't have Wi-Fi and he's
like Amazon ain't even a thing in the
hood yeah you guys like like we don't
listen to podcasts we don't have watt
and I'm sitting there thinking like
Amazon's not a thing and and and I'm
like a lot a lot of people that I am
familiar with live like this and ya know
that yeah you know but that's a really
powerful thing
I'm telling like in and that was
probably one of the most coolest things
to me is to bring an environment or
perspective to a place and to have like
honest conversation about it yeah I'm
saying just how the state of America is
like the state of America has never been
so intense when it comes to race right
ever you know I don't know if they fill
it out here in Los Angeles but
everywhere else you go in America you
feel like that but to talk about the
culture and to not be offended to be
easy going to laugh to joke to say [ __ ]
it's normally tougher now you have
people in different environments who are
like yo okay I've had a chance to digest
this information outside of like just
one side either it's a left-wing or
right-wing way conversation this is just
an independent conversation I think that
just helps to add just to America are
the people's perspective yeah now I
agree I mean in in LA you guys also have
a gift I think that like in LA and all
right I feel like sometimes we can't
even talk about stuff you know like it
would be it's scary like it's scary to
have like race conversations and stuff
out here because people also don't even
understand what the rest of America is
kind of really like you know a lot of
people out here are third fourth
generation Los Angeles people and
because Hollywood people yeah that's the
thing the rest of LA is totally cool man
you get out into some of these suburbs
and like the Latino kids and stuff like
that they're [ __ ] they get it they
joke around like like crazy like
ridiculous but then you get into some of
these more like Hollywood circles and
it's like man you have to just you just
turn into such a muppet man then it's
almost exhausting yes it would be a
little because exhausting is you gotta
get to be free it doesn't connect to
your soul and like like at the end of
the day man if you're connecting to
vanity you're connecting the [ __ ]
and you're sort of putting on this suit
artists mask artists persona that just
doesn't really tap into you at some
point that [ __ ] just runs its course
yeah I don't know [ __ ] who you are I
don't go [ __ ] how much money it's like
the beautiful girl who gets with the
ugly guy because he has money and then
after all of the the chills and thrills
and the boats and the planes and all
that [ __ ] wears off she wakes up like
now what the [ __ ]
cuz you named d'Artagnan like but it
wears itself out but you have guys who
hoard themselves out because like John's
back home I'm in California me and John
grew up together on the internet I want
to look cooler than John and that's
where it stops right and then I sell
myself and I'm not a whole person you
know saying but like I think just the
preservation of that and I like as well
as we're talking I'm like Dan we hit on
a lot of topics my pocket yeah I'm just
thinking about the shallowness thing
that you said and I'm going through my
head and running through this feeling of
hat being able to have a partner of the
opposite race that's black yeah that on
a couple shows I've been able to look at
and this is what I believe needs to
happen more in America I've been able to
look at them and through a conversation
use the word [ __ ] because that's
what's going on right like I think it's
a gift to have someone of an opposite
race to have a discussion where you
could be like these are how
[ __ ] are talking right now in
certain places right so we're in a given
context for yeah a person has it taken
the wrong way to be like this is blunt
this is [ __ ] and in parts of the
country that people say it in you some
people can't say and it's uncomfortable
than they hear oh and listen it's come
back proved this way it's come back
strong and that's just what it is and I
want to know and I'm comfortable enough
and I feel blessed about you to have a
guide then I could talk right to a black
man and say what is it like when you're
[ __ ] standing outside at out at a
food truck and some dude rolls by and
says [ __ ] you [ __ ]
yeah like that's a real conversation and
I think that's how we start maybe to
make progress right and these surface
conversations you refer to that you're
scared of like the only way to like get
through that is to the wall down you
know it's like [ __ ] that I'm gonna live
in this world if I can't have a real
conversation with you I don't want to
[ __ ] talk to you right let me give
reference to two people who may not so
John's not racist if anybody made
I like try to defend you so like people
know I can't it now is this guy you know
is this guy racist no he's not racist
but I think his personality his
bluntness of his foreigners allows us to
like because he may have that thought in
his head you know and he wants to know
this question this is the thing that
happened I lived in South Carolina I
heard five white guys walking down the
street every night you know going to the
bars and Charleston I didn't hear that
ten years ago right this is real and I
want to know I'm not saying it I want to
know how a black man feels of this is
right that matters to me right so so
being able to take it that far not be
offended not feel in any way about like
I'm like he's I've experienced enough
even from prison right I was in prison
with this guy named Chad Chad was
deported Aryan Brotherhood and I asked
Chad I'm like yo like why do you dislike
black people I think I said it's one of
our early episodes he just like Maurice
I've never grew up around me and so I
was like well he doesn't really not like
black people he just never grew up
around him yeah no different than like
somebody who just never grew up around
people like he's like I'm just choosing
to stay around white guys and I just
want to be around white guys because
this is what I'm familiar with and so I
didn't look at channels like a back I'm
like this [ __ ] just ignorant
right now see he just never been exposed
so like to be able to have these
conversations like are or even I have
the conversation I'm a black guy who
lives in a neighborhood where I know how
I don't feel accepted right but I don't
want to be in a hood I don't want to be
in the suburbs and so you have these
conversations and so now I have people
who are of a different race who could
tell me like this is how people feel
right this is but but but so now we're
dealing with the truth now right
you know Sam but then these people may
not like me for fictitious reasons so
like actually why don't you like that a
black person is living in neighborhood
and who is it that I don't like her what
is it that I don't like about you
but peeling that stuff back makes this
conversation real yeah and so now we're
dealing with the human facade but now we
can grow if we've dealt with the reality
of stuff but being able to talk about
but but in in business these are all
factors into people dealing with each
other right how to deal with other
people's and then that that plays into
all business so you're taken to business
and boss you
taking all the psychology bro but we did
but yeah dealing with all with each
other rather these are employees rather
these are people answer your calls to
pass you off to the right person rather
these are people introduced until you
rather they have a preconceived notion
before y'all get together these are all
things that make all of us up but you
tell me right now where you gonna go get
this conversation without being
ridiculed about that happening right now
saying you're not gonna get it anywhere
but in America this is a [ __ ] factor
but I appreciated I'm here to where it's
a it's a respectful and wholesome and I
don't take [ __ ] personal conversation
because like we're trying to get to a
space to working like okay let's get
some resolve and grow from this like
that's it that's the front side that's
the intention right yeah let's get some
yeah I like it no I mean I think it
shows that you guys are yeah I mean it's
one of the gifts of you guys is dynamic
is that you can talk openly not happen
to anywhere else made right and peeling
back that poverty's poverty man whether
you're a white kid from Appalachia or
yourself from the hood of Youngstown
from southside of Chicago where it all
of that it's different factors and it
might be different parts of the country
but its resources its education its
opportunity it's dude that's what it is
yeah and racism a lot of times and
hatred and stuff like that when you're
poor man it's just though if you have
nothing else you know reference and but
also sometimes it's the only thing you
can do you have nothing you have no
education the one thing you have control
over is your homeboy bow has a
confederate flag on its truck and you're
like half right is to hate somebody you
know and it's like yeah I mean it's
sometimes it's just like a thing that
comes in poverty poor people love to
fight it's all they have to do it you
know it's like that's what to take pride
in and it's a free with summary to do
you know I'm saying you were lucky if
somebody would have cut their hair
laughing I'm not sure
remember when if somebody cut their hose
on let's use their water they were like
keeping a watch on how much water you
get out the hose like there's some of
this [ __ ] was ridiculous you know um
yeah but I think it is a gift of you
guys is a podcast man I think it's one
of the things that's neat and I think
it's a I agree it's conversations that
need to be heard you know like I mean I
grew up if you know they
had yeah you I just didn't realize when
I was growing up you would see black
families you like oh they don't care
about themselves you know that's what
you would think you know you would see a
black family you know it'd be like you
know I won't give you the thought from
saying that they don't care about it
themselves probably would you physically
see my process I would see like you know
probably they're you know they you know
maybe the their neighborhood they didn't
try to keep their neighborhood up or
they didn't you know like the parents
were smoking weed or you know the mom
was smoking weed the kid was buying weed
for the mom you know um or also things
you know it's a really great question
you know I guess like oh the kids some
of the kids couldn't you know we had
kids in seventh grade that couldn't talk
even really you know and they were in
seventh grade
you know black kids right and so then it
made you think I guess actually I didn't
it made me think oh they don't care
about themselves no now as I get older
and now I live out here and I see more
of the world you know and I understand
that like oh well if you have generation
after generation of a family not having
any income or if the grandfather gets a
parking ticket and that means that the
son you know the grandson isn't gonna
get a Christmas gift you know like if
it's that fine of a line now as I get
older oh you see it it's so much clearer
but from me as a child being in an
environment you don't see it and you
also don't get the information nobody's
telling me this my perspective that I
scan am able to see now and then also
black and white people fight all the
time so or would be fighting so then you
have this other thing where it's like
you know are we even allowed to get
along like do they hate me you know and
then like yes I mean it's a messy
environment sometimes you know and and I
feel bad about some of the ways probably
that I thought as a kid but as a child
someone will probably survival
mechanisms and they were thoughts that
you know I needed maybe at certain
points to make me feel a certain way or
and sometimes safety mechanisms you know
like I grew up in poor black and white
and those people were there was a lot of
fighting sometimes and so I was scared
of both of those a lot of those people
sometimes not
all of them you know someone had friends
in both areas but in within poverty
there was a much more of a chance yes or
volatility and that's what made me
really really nervous you know yeah
major thing as I'm listening to you you
know black and white poverty are
probably very similar in terms of the
things you reference about not being
able to speak or not keeping up your
yard or something like that but like a
crucial part to everything whether it
goes back three generations or four
generations is like everybody has to
take it upon themselves and we talk
about this a lot to break the cycle and
it's the hardest [ __ ] thing to do
because your family doesn't understand
you
your relatives don't understand you but
there's always got to be one there's
always got to be one in the family
that's like [ __ ] this no more [ __ ]
800 square foot house with the roof leak
and like I'm gonna do something about
that right like there's got to be one
and we're all those ones yeah and I
think that's why I resonate you know
with you guys's podcast I mean it's
funny like mob and one thing that I've
learned is my brother now you know he
started a successful business and tree
business right he doesn't like trees
really but he likes business you know so
he realized now he's like Tamra if I see
a dam to buy for him but to slit my
throat with it you know but he loves
business but one thing he realizes
looking back in our neighborhood is just
child psychology and so that's what he
wants to get into now and so he uses
like the YMCA and it's like very it's
extremely black and white kids over
there and he doesn't really see a
difference you know we don't see some of
the same differences we saw his kids but
to see him wanted to help children so
much no matter who they are you know as
a competitor you change a community
right in and he's really a big
inspiration to me but but it's uh when I
really think I was think about this the
other day when I really think back the
kids that I associated with the most
were kids that felt this I could see
felt the same way that I did which was
that and it didn't matter if they were
black and white it also was a color that
was within us it was some other gray
color within us or a confused color
within us it came from like our space
our struggling yeah like a space of
struggling and probably a space of just
not really having
you know structure within to know how to
handle just day-to-day situations not
knowing when to be confident not knowing
you know because sometimes your
confidence would get strayed you'd be
confident at a time if you look with the
[ __ ] man confident right now force a
spelling bee you know you you appear you
know whatever you hear yelling and
screaming about vowels like calm it down
you know how'd you how'd you get the
confidence to say you know what I'm
funny I'm gonna go after this [ __ ] how'd
you get it oh you know I don't know
sometimes I think sometimes it's one of
those things that kind of stayed it was
like this this light that stayed in me
that I needed I think it was a defense
mechanism and I was young you know I
couldn't really physically take care of
myself much so I had to joke I had to be
the jokester and then joking kind of
transcended you could like black kids
love to joke around white kids like it
you know it was you were kind of the
jokester was always welcome everywhere
unless he joke too much then you got
your ass beat yeah yeah that was a risky
lot I run the line but no I mean look
this is I mean even moment to this
conversation have been a little bit
uncomfortable for me but not in a bad
way
sure and I recognize that because I'm in
a place where you know I know you guys
are you know people that care about the
end of this conversation and the next
week in the next year and the next 20
years of of you know of young men and
young women growing and you know we're
not just thinking about you know this
moment right here and I feel that and I
feel that when the list you guys podcast
I mean it's ridiculous you know I still
don't know if fosco should be allowed on
the air
me and Maurice always look at each other
like this mother person I realize he W a
bro it's real I got him like this guy's
ham and I'll get him on track bro I
never fit oh dude he could be in the
easily listen we have a disclaimer
before I speak before what he does is
that he pushes the boundaries on what
we're talking about always right so he
pushes so one things right so one I
realize use that introspective and
intelligent so they made some people
think you're a comedian when I listen to
people what they say it's the same thing
with hell yeah I sometimes people's
personality be so harsh that people
forget
they like [ __ ] deep introspective
well-thought our people yeah
his personality may be different in
yours you from coming from yeah I feel
you know I'm referencing John to people
who are talking you gotta see this John
Fusco guy man I can't even this guy's
I'm not checking I never met anybody
like this dude man but everybody push he
pushes Cory would you conversation would
agree yeah he pushes and then it may
come off harsh and brutal and tough but
then his father's a dead on though right
it's followed up to leverage it by
something intellectual and then you can
volley with the conversation back and
forth and at the end of it you say okay
he may have come with me hard but if I
digest what the [ __ ] he said he's not
[ __ ] lie like they met my girl listen
to the manager dick program but it's
true harsh here's like let my man Johnny
you know yes
[ __ ] kinda like make sense yeah I
mean I think if when you gloss over
things you're you're increasing the
probability that people don't do not
take them and understand them and digest
them clearly well if you come right down
the middle
it may sound harsh they may think you're
an [ __ ] or they may love you that
they normally go one or two ways but at
least you're giving real information and
I don't [ __ ] care who likes me right
I actually like to be not liked because
if you like me that that's cool but I I
have like this responsibility I've
always felt this to the truth and if
it's not the truth
[ __ ] you [ __ ] who have like get out of
my face bro like I want nothing to do
yeah like I don't play any of those
games and and that's and that to me is
beauty because that that's purity when
you're speaking in truth bro that's the
substance that's where it's at once you
you know we always say we don't talk
about things I can talk about my car my
house is for what right who's that
benefit right nobody let's talk about
the skills yeah we can give people to
not just get things but become better
people help their family and and [ __ ]
be happy yeah and
if you don't like the way I say it [ __ ]
you yeah I think that concept I think
that being uncomfortable though is huge
the achieves is that so I like I told
John the other day so far it would have
it coming off on another venture it had
been really easy for me to just kind of
coast and be comfortable John I like him
and he keeps you uncomfortable right so
some people don't they dislike John
because of that they just don't [ __ ]
with him he where it's only pushed me to
be better and I told him at the other
day like bro I just appreciate it
because it would be much easier for me
to just kind of coast and because I know
what I've got myself into that it's
going there's going to be uncomfortable
moments over talking reference to
business because we have multiple
businesses together he keeps pushing and
the podcast being one of them he's gonna
push the limits which makes you go a
little bit deeper on things and you know
try to reverse and push him and that's
what we've been doing all three of us
and to your point on on changing that
change in the cycle breaking the cycle I
want to ask you is what you've been able
to do broke the cycle for your family is
it given your family like a new breath
of air that things are possible like
from where you come from I think so i
mean i think you know i think one thing
for me honestly like you know a lot of
my families ended up with addiction you
know it's been like a big thing in our
family and I think um yeah I just have
learned a lot about you know it makes me
real or for some reason it makes me feel
really sad when somebody doesn't know
what how much they're valued you know
and that really for some reason like it
breaks my heart you know and I think
because I I think as a kid I needed just
somebody to know that they valued me you
know and my mother worked really really
hard you know she worked you know
delivered newspapers and still does and
you know and and I think she never was
taught at some of those things you know
and so then yeah then I'm able to see a
lot of the cycles you know and then when
I watched like even when I watched like
you know Maurice is 34 30 like there's a
you know I couldn't connect on a lot of
football stuff I could connect like from
a fan perspective like I look it's so
much fun and like you know did they
really beat Miami and I got
no I could connect on like but then I I
could connect there was there was a
moment rock connected like oh man I
wonder if that young man knew how much
he was valued as a kid you know like I
wonder if he got the love that he you
know like that's where it made me think
like man that's that might be a place
that I have in common with that man not
that I needed have him to have it in
common with me but that's a place where
I could feel something you know and
that's the part that I really and that's
the part that now when I go back into a
community I'll look at a kid you know
where I look at a family or anybody I'm
able to see it from you know from that
and that's where I feel like I know in
my heart that's a place that I can
that's this place that I can start to
help at you know have fun some way to
let people know that they're valued you
know but yeah I mean I think for some of
the race stuff it just took a getting a
bigger perspective it's hard when you're
in those perspectives and you know when
you're in the end when you're in a small
place it's hard to see the big picture
you know well as long as you get to a
place where you figure it out or at
least you hear the information I think
that's very important and the reason I
like to talk about it so much because
you deal with on a daily basis yeah you
know sometimes we only like to talk
about racing like these harsh conditions
or just like an extreme view one way or
another or you have some sort of you
know police shooting or the race gets
commercialized with the karlon Kapernick
deal and sometimes you lose the actual
message of what's going on but if you
don't have these conversations then you
don't deal to truth and if you don't
deal the truth are you not working
towards to shift the perspective to
where you know we all [ __ ] people at
the end of the day like nobody's better
than nobody and you know you don't have
to have a harsh perspective on somebody
because they're black or white and even
you know you do a racism and you do a
classism and just because the person
doesn't have as much as you do it
doesn't mean that they're they're less
than you right and so and so you have
that stuff and to and to talk about that
it's a platform to do about I just think
it's to be responsible with your voice
and for anybody who's been through any
hardship like if you've been through
addiction there's no way that you can
feel that you're better than anybody
yeah because you've been [ __ ] up and
you've been not been able to take care
of yourself and you're not been
responsible at some point so at some
point you were like the person who's
vulnerable or the person who comes from
the lower socioeconomic background but
it's the same thing with everything but
those are the human things and and and
like I say I know this is about our
podcast by having the vehicle and the
people who come from those backgrounds
and to be able to talk about it out
there
bless bro its doodles I believe it's the
only weapon to move let's say maybe the
two hardest things in this country
forward having a white man and a black
man talk about real issues when they
don't have to have those conversations
could happen in every county in every
house every day that that's gonna move
something racially forward yeah let's
say you take one political side now on
the other political side you don't have
to agree but if you can just have a
civilized dialogue you will find hey I
might not agree with you but we got [ __ ]
in common bro yeah they're cool and no
one's willing to have those
conversations because we're so divided
and and and and now and that is
ignorance at it's finest divided with
trivial [ __ ] and like how many times we
have this conversation
yeah with trivial stuff trivial [ __ ]
right an old-school [ __ ] it's like old
school stuff is that like plays out 30
years later so extra stuff like this
when one axis off this one have you ever
had platforms who have these
conversations right these what these
conversations not happen in the [ __ ]
Town Hall no what are you driving to
school no oh we congregating at the
library talking about there's no
podcasts or platforms which you can draw
right you're not going to the radio
station to say yo like 107 to whatever
[ __ ] it is you know can we you don't
here we have this conversation talk
about that you know just let me get a
little further into it what do we have
like some some representative who think
he represents all black people you have
somebody would end up with an agenda
who's been sharp income this is what it
is but you know these [ __ ] come
and they don't represent all voices they
want to be a super song and it also
there's a level of achievement that
they're trying to achieve yes so as soon
as I was not honest
so I'm not about to cry about the fact
that we didn't have it I just want to
know it so this was a I would say well
it would inspire them even more it's the
University of Maryland Virginia one of
those Rutgers one of the University I
was telling you all about they had a
session where they were hosting for
white kids how to deal racism as I'm
looking at the [ __ ] I said on a college
campus you are inviting a space for all
white kids to just understand how to
process this [ __ ] so somebody had the
foresight to say this is a real [ __ ]
thing and kids may have feelings that
they feel about something or incorrect
information so how do I deal with this
[ __ ] with the climate in America so you
have to ask yourself right if they're
[ __ ] giving a [ __ ] to kids on a
college campus right and you're hosting
a safe space for these kids to express
themselves because that's probably the
space where a person can't say just like
John say you know there's people in our
neighborhood may think or look at you
all as [ __ ] you know saying like
that's a real thing in America and that
same person who feels that way maybe the
same person that [ __ ] Starbucks are
the same person at the [ __ ] local gas
station and until you have healthy
dialogue with these people nothing's
gonna change these people are gonna grow
up with these saying views you know
saying it hasn't changed I mean you know
a lot of the stuff it's just been the
same types of things that haven't really
changed that much bro like so what are
the incentives to change them right when
you really some dollars so for me just a
better [ __ ] in America was an individual
level but unfortunately keep on like a
tackle drill over here yeah yeah but
like outside of individuals what are the
incentives I mean you always got to
follow the money and the people who
control our [ __ ] that's why voting is so
important
hey they make the rules and they don't
have right now there's a huge incentive
to keep us divided yeah a huge oh I
agree and unless just open our eyes yeah
and and and say well what can we do
about it don't throw your hands up like
a [ __ ] and say I can't do anything
about it have hard conversations you
know try to find real people but yeah I
mean we're in these conditions because
the people who we voted for
contribute to them yeah yeah I mean it's
uh it's wild man and you know it's so
funny you say pushes the boundaries and
then growth you were talking about as
well because yeah when you said that a
little bit ago I'm like [ __ ] now that
was like this space in the room right
but then we had to fill the space you
know absolutely and that's what I mean
it was just it was really really
interesting but yeah I mean I think
there's a lot of I think yeah racism
stuff cuz there's a lot of like white
people I think like you know I grew up I
got jump a couple times about black kids
you know and it made me I mean I grew up
in fear of like some of the white kids
in our neighborhood and I got beat up by
some of them a couple times but it made
me so then when I would see like a group
of black guys sometimes this is a
therapy session oh yeah but it's like I
would get scared you know and I didn't
want to be I think I didn't want to be
angry like in my heart I didn't want to
be angry at black people but I would be
scared of those types of kids and if I
saw a replica of a group like that or
something my head it's just like you
know if a doberman attached you then we
see a doberman you're gonna be nervous
you know get the film absolutely so I
had a lot of those feelings and I think
you know I think there's probably a lot
of like you know other people that have
had similar type of feelings yeah but
it's the same like but don't get me
wrong black people are scared of black
people yeah you know and it's not the
black people's two behavior in the
environment you know why people are
scared white oh I would get scared if
Noah there's a couple of those look
there's some dudes in my neighborhood
who you know allegedly it killed a
couple people with a truck you know and
it's just like man I'm swayed so we're
walking through life with these
prejudices parties but I'm just being
earnest about things that I've thought
no but it's cool like I mean you you say
that it's no different than how I may
feel towards a white person who comes in
in my community as a young black kid
another your police officer or whether
you just white in your neighborhood what
the hell are you doing here you know
saying things that you don't know are
really believing we're gonna believe in
that all white people are racist you
know like they just don't like black
people you know said but that's not true
not true you know but think about media
dude okay so so I always say this and
people can judge me for whatever as a
man I'm sorry that that pit that that's
that that's ever been a perception it's
a
makes me sad too but it's ignorance
right the perception is built from
ignorance like what is what is I'm sorry
if this upsets listeners but what does
Fox News put out there they put out
pictures of Black Panthers at voting
booths you know I'm saying like like
this is what's consumed for like six to
eight hours by a lot of America I ain't
dog and Fox know it could be MSNBC going
the other way but like these this is
what people are consuming so they may
not even have to get a beating right
they see it on TV and they're like I'm
not going to the voting booth Black
Panthers are there right now right it's
like the same with the Charlottesville
thing like yeah they had some racist
kids with the bracelets young people or
middle-aged people that showed up there
right people that we don't need anywhere
you know like it not a type of hatred
you want anywhere but then to make it
seem like it's a hundred thousand people
and a pop you know that scares so many
people and makes things a lot more
you know racist than they really are
divided you know yeah because they keep
us the more news we make the more
fighting the new stays in business we go
to war the news will cover it and we
stay they stay in business insider
ratings
yeah why they stand outside getting
blown around by a merese brought up on
the podcast one time Theo that running
at the track in the morning so I'm at
the track of the time right yeah and I'm
out there running lunging the early
Dundee yeah three but so I'm up there
you know running lunging akka willing
he's wait up for than me so I'm gonna
stay up all night basically so you know
I'm at the track and there's other
people there in the morning I'm lunging
my 800 meters and things I do and and I
don't think no different it doesn't
matter if the person's white black
purple walking around the track Marie
says and I'm in a black hoodie hooded up
the whole nine right Marie says I'm at
the track and there's a a white woman
running or walking by and I'm not here
by myself then it makes me like oh yeah
it's the thought that goes through that
I never even would even think about Theo
when he brought it up on the podcast I
was like man up [ __ ] but it's real it's
250 pounds he's a [ __ ] big dude and
it's on bluehost it's black in the night
you're talking about
hold that ball from Sean Taylor that one
oh he's got the grip so it's like those
things those things those things are
real bro and it's like a lot of people
wouldn't even think that that's even a
thing but this thing is so just think
about that yeah that is a real thing
every time I go to the track to the
point I can grab my phone and show you
what my lawyer I text the lawyer said
look this is weird but I'm texting you
but I'm this is right now I'm at ya
serious [ __ ]
but I'm thinking myself that anything
can be said and my life can be altered
or she can feel nervous or whatever it
is I'm a but but but as simple [ __ ] I
can even when I go to the gym in the
morning I can I can without a shadow of
a doubt if you want a treadmill I don't
want to be about a black guy if I'm
lifting weights in a certain area I
don't want to be about a black guy and
it's almost weird to the point like I'm
the black guy until somebody introduces
me as Maurice Clarett and then when I
get introduces Maurice Clarett oh this
is a cool [ __ ] yeah he's from coming
from like now it's acceptable to talk to
me so my head it plays like who the [ __ ]
was that before I became Maurice Clarett
to you you know saying but these are
real things you know saying like stuff
that they never think about I even we
walk out here in LA like I know if I'm
around them and talking with them like
it's easier it's easier for me it's
easier for you to talk to me when I'm -
what - white guys right if I'm coming
from literally you don't you like you
don't go through this right when I go to
the barbershop based upon what event
that I'm about to do
okay I got to shave my face because I'm
a little bit more softer on people you
know send a beer makes me look a lot
more aggressive and a lot more this is
but yes this is just not my story this
is a story of preconceived prejudices
and all this stupid [ __ ] right you know
saying and what I'm saying is like to
have somebody you can volley
conversation it's not that business and
bicep but I don't want to get this
perception that we just deal with race
no it's okay this is good this is a
conversation that you know like this is
the kind of thing is that you know
things happen on you guys's podcasts
that can be just a good conversation it
just is just a good conversation amongst
other stuff that we're talking about but
the fact that race has been so vacant
from America and people's conversation
you can look at it as if like it's this
distant
but you deal with it every day and
that's all I'm saying you know saying
and it prepares you to work with others
right yes digging into race and you go
and get a job in an office with ten
people or a hundred like this stuff will
prepare you to work with the Muslim who
your dad said you know attacked us on
9/11 right you hear this shitty like all
right none of that so it's important it
all ties to business at all tie back
there's always a meaning and I think the
meaning should never be about any of us
it should just be about like hey trying
to share this [ __ ] with you yeah yeah I
think sometimes no I love this man I
love even having the opportunity to talk
to even think about this you know I mean
sometimes I guess I get intimidated by
black guys because I feel like they're
cooler than me so I'm not joking bro I'm
really serious like a hip-hop culture
drives good know if I saw three black
guys that were like that looked cool
yeah
I'm not joking I think it's over this is
a real fear I don't know what the fear
is called but I'm not joking man I feel
really intimidated like not that they
yeah I guess I am Scott chess is gonna
break down oh is it but I feel that I
feel that I'll try to I don't know what
is I'm not saying that they that they
that they're angry at me or that I'm a
I'm just saying like like I get in I
would get more intimidated about three
like cool-looking black guys then like
three like if it was three cool-looking
white guys I would just probably think
like oh those are rich guys whatever
dude but if it was freakin black on for
somebody I would feel intimidated and it
could just be me personally thing you
know it probably is but kind of focus I
love maybe yeah maybe I'm not as cool I
can't be as cool as those guys maybe
that's what I don't know me and yeah hip
hip hop culture is cool culture is cool
I think you know yeah I think it just
looks better
I think hip hop culture looks better
home but but I don't Yemen
you know what's so funny I the first
time in my life that I ever
I was out about a year and a half ago
out here I was having a tough time
getting any traction in my career and
they you know this is
a lot of like a lot of during the
political stuff and everybody out here
was like [ __ ] all white people from the
Midwest and from the you know and from
South like anybody that I even sounded
like like my father's from Nicaragua
right my mother's from Chicago my Peoria
Illinois but anybody that even sounded
like me or look like me they were this
you know this is bad we don't want this
on the air this is not what we're going
for this guy doesn't have a chance here
right now they're so liberal out here it
was so liberal I mean dude we couldn't
even we couldn't even speak but here's
an interesting moment that happened to
me I was like man I felt I felt bad
about the way that I looked I felt bad
about the way that I sounded and I felt
like because of those two things I
wasn't gonna be able to live out my
dreams which were to be you know in in
the entertainment industry so you feel
like a black person so there was a
moment for the first time I was like wow
this must be what it feels like to be to
be black sometimes or to be of may be a
woman you know to be yet but the first
thing I thought was impressed because of
something you can't change but I never
had that much Rubik's Cube kind of shift
in one moment you think about like this
so if you felt like that in the moment
imagine how a lot of black people feel
all the time yeah that before we even
get to if I'm talented enough or skilled
enough or am I even acceptable to do
what you being asked for I got a deal
with how I look and how I sound you do
basically say the same thing I said what
how I got like so the reason I cussed a
whole lot is to let people know you can
you know they'd say curse words and
still make it reason I'm myself all the
time amongst each - it's like you can
still be yourself you don't have to be
at a [ __ ] or Uncle Tom or you don't have
to switch who you are in order to make
it in life like you can still be
yourself and I think that that in itself
is my responsibility rather they feel
like it's brother some people are turned
off by it rather they say it's not
professional enough but even even here
you said I was like wow I didn't realize
how that can be an adverse affect to you
because some people may identify you as
like he's a trump supporter or he may be
somebody who looks like people who hate
black people and we don't want this to
be either represent to be involved with
this right but to even feel like that is
to feel like how a lot of people feel
and even though in certain segments or
parts of America people don't deal with
this so we shouldn't have to deal with
is I think it's just like this thing my
stupid idea though
yeah like rafting like that has to be a
thing you know yeah I couldn't imagine
that I can barely get out of my car no
make sure my [ __ ] shoes are tied I
can imagine you know at that point
though from a success standpoint because
a lot of people when they when they deal
with doubt or circumstances that are
challenging they say maybe I should
adapt Who I am or maybe I should come at
it differently when I think we all know
the key to any kind of success is
authenticity pure authenticity did you
ever at any point in that process say
maybe I got a dial back the accent maybe
I got a [ __ ] with the haircut maybe I
got to be less of me to make it out here
which I it's a question no it's a great
question I did I mean I actually for a
while I tried to sound like really
really mainstream and not be myself you
know I think I grew this haircut out
because I looked at a picture of myself
and I'd always had short hair and I have
a big nose so it's like you can hide a
big nose better if you got Italy no more
hair something you know like that I mean
yeah okay sorry but you can but so those
were things that some of this was
insecurities but then once I started
growing my hair out I was like oh man oh
I I saw a picture of myself I said I
never want to see mas I'll never know
what it's like to have long hair in my
whole life because all my pictures are
short hair I said may I'll change it up
a little and just try yeah try something
wild you know and in Canada this is a
hockey haircut and Canada you just what
you think this they think you play for
the Canadians but here it down here it's
like they don't know what you do but out
of man I I look forward to coming I'd
love to come on you guys is podcast I'll
be in Columbus some an even announced
he's tour dates yet but it'll be in the
early early spring oh yeah we can't wait
to watch it so I'd love to talk about
this kind of stuff some more II just
think about it man you know I can't wait
this is a oh this is I haven't won I've
enjoyed myself and to I'm glad I didn't
listen to you before I came on because
now you know he's like [ __ ] you in his
head ya know so like I was like not
wanna sit okay it's got cheesy right oh
yeah yes sometimes no dude the level of
queso is you start to get over
it builds up on you bruh you can't help
oh but they're like after you start
talking and and like I there's a there's
a deep sense of intelligence when you
talk because I could tell people like
I've read enough and listened to enough
people you could tell through cadence
two words I think purpose how to use
them how to leverage them and you could
tell when somebody's volume back and
forefoot conversation I would say if I'm
not good a lot of [ __ ] I think I'm good
at that and because I think in prison
you [ __ ] hear people talk all day
yeah and so you can like you know you
pick up on [ __ ] well your instincts are
probably pretty acute a bit yeah man
there you go so no I don't know I don't
know I've thoroughly enjoyed myself and
I'm pretty sure I think that our
conversations never stop and I
absolutely love to have you when you're
in Columbus yes that's the whole deal
with our stuff these conversations they
don't have an end point we're always
working to get to a better place and
we'll die working to get to a better
place
I can't tell somebody when John talks
before like I feel like I'm in like in
the military one moment no no it's great
man no I love knowing that I have people
that I could talk to you about business
you know I love knowing that if I you
know this is cool you know I'm a big fan
of you guys dude and I'm really really
really grateful him that you guys came
out here you know Maurice I think one
thing that you do have a gift is being
like a liaison to people you know and
connecting people because I mean that is
one of the benefits of having a name you
know is that you get to be a bridge you
know you really you know as much as
people someone's want to use you as a
staircase probably I bet a lot more
people probably to use you as a bridge
you know yeah hopefully hopefully
through this podcast we can do just that
hopefully we get people who listen and
hopefully people who I can I've had a
ton of people I gotta say now one of the
biggest y'all was talking on earlier one
of the biggest things happens around a
[ __ ] stake his shake nice taking
shakes to enter now no I love Shake
Shack goes no so I wasn't selling
tequila no Penn Station again they said
this steak cheesesteaks
a guy came up to me any guy was like man
and I thought he's gonna say something
about football he's like man I listen to
y'all podcast every [ __ ] day and when
he said it he emphasized he said you
don't realize I learned so much [ __ ]
from there and so that to me yeah and
when I get DMS from dudes and these
dudes are naming specific things from
what we're talking about and my dudes
were sending me text messages about [ __ ]
that we talked about dude that is the
most rewarding thing to let you know
that you are doing what you're supposed
to be doing and I think in life when you
when you can do what you are meant to do
and you can connect to people in the way
that you want to connect like that is
the greatest [ __ ] and I think that that
is like what leaves an impact on people
yeah I agree man I mean yeah it's well
said yeah I think we're you guys good
man
real good man yeah awesome John Corey
Maurice thank you so much Nick we good
yeah just super grateful you guys are
here and uh and I look forward to doing
it on you guys's podcast in the spring
this is a business and biceps crew here
on this past weekend thank you guys very
much thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
when I reach that round I'll share this
piece of thought it's gonna take
[Music]
Wow you know what's crazy as my sister
can't even read it but what does it have
to do with us right now hope you enjoyed
that video and you can watch another and
you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices some guy just brings you one
option not this guy
two options watch one this one